ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
MEMBERS PLEASE COME TO THE FLOOR.
SO THEY YOU ARE INCLUDED IN THE
ASSEMBLY OFFICIAL PHOTO FOR THE
YEAR.
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA POWER QUE
HAN.
BERMAN BIGELOW.
BLOOM BURNER **** BATH.
BONTA.
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY.
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
ALL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ.
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS.
REYES THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SMITH STONE.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR.
PLEASE REPORT TO THE FLOOR
IMMEDIATELY
IS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
GRAYSON.
MR RACING.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THOUGHT AND
PRAYER.
THE UNIVERSES STARS MOONS AND
THE SUN.
THE OCEANS IN THE MOUNTAINS THE
FRUIT OF THE TREES IN THE
STREAMS THAT GLISTEN ON THE
VALLEY FLOORS.
ALL TESTIFY OF THE GREATNESS BY
WHICH WE HAVE ALL BEEN CAREFULLY
AND WONDERFULLY MADE.
MOVE UPON OUR LEADERS ON EVERY
LEVEL.
WHETHER BE FEDERAL STATE OR
LOCAL WITH A MORAL PERSPECTIVE
THE CHALLENGES EACH ELECTED
OFFICIAL TO SUPPORT.
PROMOTE AND INITIATE POLICIES
THAT TRULY DEFINE A NATION THAT
WHOLE HEARTEDLY UPHOLDS THE
STANDARD THAT ALL ARE CREATED
EQUAL.
AND THAT HATE BIGOTRY AND
PREJUDICE HAVE NO PLACE IN THE
FIBER AND FABRIC OF OUR SOCIETY.
GIVE EACH OF US THE WISDOM GOOD
JUDGMENT AND COMMON SENSE TO
EXERCISE JUSTICE AND MERCY IN AN
ENVIRONMENT OF PROVISION AND
GRACE.
AS WE FULFILL THE DUTIES SET
BEFORE US. TO LEAVE THIS STATE
IN A WAY WHERE EQUITY FOR ALL
AND IN ALL IS THE STANDARD.
SOFTEN THE HEARTS OF THOSE THAT
HAVE TWO COATS THAT THEY MAY
GIVE TO THEM WHO HAVE NONE.
LET US EXACT NO MORE FROM THE
PEOPLE THAN WHAT IS APPOINTED.
PROVIDE FOR THOSE IN NEED
SAFEGUARD THE VULNERABLE PLACE
OUR HEARTS TO BEAR ONE ANOTHER'S
BURDENS AND DIRECT THOSE WHO ARE
BLESSED TO BECOME THE BLESSING.
INSTILL WITHIN EACH OF US A
RESPECT ONE FOR ANOTHER AND A
REVERENCE FOR THE FREE WILL THE
EACH OF US HAVE BEEN DIVINELY
GIVEN.
NOT FORGETTING THE PRINCIPLE OF
DOING ON TO OTHERS.
AS YOU WOULD HAVE THEM DO UNTO
YOU.
SHINE YOUR LIGHT UPON OUR PATH
AS WE LOOK TO BE AN EXAMPLE TO
OUR NATION AND TO OUR WORLD.
NOW LET YOUR PRESENCE AND I'M
GOING TO BE UPON THIS HOUSE AS
WE STRIVE FOR POLICIES AND
SOLUTIONS THAT IMPACT THE LIVES
OF THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN GIVEN THE
CHARGE TO REPRESENT.
A MAN.
THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
ABOUT.
READY BEGAN I PLEDGE
[inaudible]
A FROM.
THE AND IS A LITTLE.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MAY NINTH
TWENTY NINETEEN THE ASSEMBLY MET
AT NINE AM ON LOWER BACK OF OUR
QUE HANNAH ASSISTANCE SPEAKER
PRO TEM OF THE STANLEY PRESIDING
CHEAP THIRTY DALTON WILSON
ADVENTURER CALDERON MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS.
AT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS.
THERE ARE NOT INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOAQUIN ARAMBULA.
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN
COOLEY.
IN FOR FUNERAL DEATH IN THE
FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
EDUARDO GARCIA
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ANYTHING A
TO ALLOW US THE SPEAKER.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BIGELOW
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF AND THE MOAN TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MCCARTY
CRISTINA GARCIA DOLLY GIPSON
PATTERSON BIGELOW TO SPEAK ON IN
SHERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
PERMIT THE MEMBERS A BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WEBER JONES
SAWYER LACKEY MELENDEZ A STONE
TO ADD THEIR VOTES TO ROLL CALL
VOTES.
TAKEN ON THIS DAY AS IF
PRESIDENT WHILE THEY ATTEND
TODAY'S BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER FIVE WHICH CONVENES.
AT TWO THIRTY PM.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER IN AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR FIFTY THREE A. B. C.
TEN SIXTY GREAT SEE AN ACTIVE
FILE.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
MEMBERS IN PREPARATION FOR THE
ASSEMBLIES PANORAMIC PHOTO.
PLEASE REMOVE ALL ITEMS PERSONAL
ITEMS FROM YOUR GAS.
AND PLEASE PLACE YOUR PURSE SAYS
OUR BRIEFCASES UNDERNEATH.
YOUR GAS PLEASE PUT THOSE ITEMS
UNDER YOUR DESK AT THIS TIME
IN
TWO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ON SECOND READING.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM
TWO FORTY SIX FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
MADAM CLERK [inaudible]
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX THE CLERK
READ THE BILL WITH AMENDMENTS.
AS AN ABLE FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX
WITH THE MAMMOTH BY SOME NUMBER
CALLED AROUND.
HEY MISTER CALDERON WILL BE
TAKEN UP THESE AMENDMENTS WHEN.
HE CHOOSES.
TO MISTER CALDERON ON THESE MMS.
THANK YOU THIS BILL WOULD DIRECT
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY TO
ESTABLISH AN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE WORKING GROUP TO
ANALYSE ETHICS IMPROPER USAGE OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
TECHNOLOGY WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS.
AND CONSUMER PRODUCTS IN THIS
THESE AMENDMENTS -- MADE WILL
ADD A MEMBER WITH A LABOR OR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BACKGROUND
TO THE WORKING GROUP.
MINOR AMENDMENT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON.
MEMBERS WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
HI OPPOSING NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
DOTTED.
THE BILLS OUT TO PRINTED BACK ON
FILE.
IN THE READING OF THE REMAINING
BILLS ON SECOND READING WILL BE
DEFERRED.
UNTIL THE END OF TODAY'S SESSION.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT SECOND READING.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB.
FIFTY SIX MS BURKE'S GOING TO
TAKE OF THE MEMBERS CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL.
FIFTY SIX REDEVELOPMENT CLERK
READ THE BILL WITH AMENDMENTS.
AS UNABLE THIRTY SIX WITH THE
MINUTES BY FAMILY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA.
M. IS BURKE WILL BE PRESENTING
AMISH GARCIA'S BEHALF MISS BURKE
ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB FIFTY SIX
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS ON
BEHALF OF THE AUTHOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
THESE AMENDMENTS SEEK TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS RAISED BY COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATORS BY MAKING THE
FOLLOWING CHANGES TO LEAVE BROAD
INTENT LANGUAGE.
CLARIFY THE AUTHORITY IS LIMITED
TO BACKSTOP PROCUREMENT.
CLARIFY THAT AB FIFTY SIX WILL
NOT EXPAND THE EXISTING
AUTHORITY OF THE PC.
THAT'S FIVE AT ANY COST WILL BE
DIRECTED ONLY TO CUSTOMERS.
WHO BENEFIT FROM THE PROCUREMENT
UNDERTAKEN BY THE AUTHORITY?
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
THANK YOU MS BURKE.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT THE PRINTER
BACK ON FILE.
AND AGAIN MEMBERS THE READING OF
THE REMAINING BILLS ON SECOND
READING WILL BE DEFERRED.
UNTIL THE END OF TODAY'S SESSION
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THIS IS THE THIRD READING FILE
WE ARE GOING.
TO TAKE OUT FILE ITEM.
FIVE SEVENTEEN WHICH IS HR.
THIRTY SEVEN BY MS CAM LONGER
JOB.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE
THAN OTHERS ABILITY TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA LOS
ANGELES.
IS KAMLAGER-DOVE OF ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I AM HERE
TODAY.
WHO EVER THOUGHT THAT I WOULD
FIND MYSELF IN THIS POSITION?
BEING A LOYAL [inaudible]
TROJAN.
DON'T START DON'T START
[inaudible]
DON'T START.
BEING A LOYAL CHOSEN AND
KNOWLEDGE SHARING.
THOUGH ONE HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY
THE CENTENNIAL.
OF ONE OF THE MOST.
PRESTIGIOUS.
AN IMPORTANT.
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES IN THIS
STATE.
AND CERTAINLY IN THE FIFTY
FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT UCLA.
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE.
A NUMBER OF BROUGH AND ALUMNI
WHO RESIDE IN THIS CHAMBER.
YET GIVEN UP FOR YOURSELVES
GIVEN UP FOR YOURSELVES.
AND SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND CERTAINLY GIVE
HONOR.
THROUGH H. R. THIRTY SEVEN TO
UCLA.
THERE WILL BE A NUMBER OF
FESTIVITIES TODAY BUT A COUPLE
OF THINGS I WANTED TO SHARE.
UCLA A HUNDRED YEARS AGO
ACTUALLY CAME INTO EXISTENCE.
UNDER INCREDIBLE ODDS.
AND IT WAS A RISKY ENDEAVOR FOR
IT TO COME INTO EXISTENCE IT WAS
FIGHTING A LOT OF OPPOSITION.
FROM BOTH THE UC REGENTS.
AND IT'S NORTHERN CAL RIVAL.
THE SCHOOL WHO SHALL NOT BE
NAMED TO BERKELEY.
AND YET IN THE MIDST OF IT ALL
WHEN IT WAS ACTUALLY -- DECIDED
THAT UCLA COULD BECOME ONE OF
OUR UC SCHOOLS.
IT WAS A TWO YEAR COLLEGE AND IT
WAS NOT ALLOWED TO GRANT DEGREES.
AND NOW A HUNDRED YEARS LATER.
US NEWS AND WORLD REPORT RANKS
IT NUMBER ONE AS A TOP
UNIVERSITY IN THE NATION.
IT RECEIVES OVER A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND YEAH.
IT RECEIVED OVER A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND APPLICANTS EACH
YEAR.
FROM ALL OF THE FIFTY STATES AND
A HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE
COUNTRIES.
AND IT IN ROLES FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS EVERY YEAR.
FROM ALL ACROSS THIS GREAT STATE
FROM THIS GREAT COUNTRY.
AND FROM COUNTRIES ACROSS THE
WORLD.
IT RANKS WITH A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN NC DOUBLE A NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIPS.
AND IT HAS AN ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR ECONOMIC IMPACT.
SO LIKE I SAID AS A TROJAN AND
YOU SHOULDN'T SAY ANYTHING
MISTER READ YOU JONES SAWYER.
I HOPE THAT YOU WILL JOIN ME AND
MY FELLOW CO AUTHORS IN
RECOGNIZING THE CENTENNIAL
ANNIVERSARY OF UCLA.
AND JOIN ME WITH YOUR AYE VOTE
FOR HR.
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU MISS
CAROLINA MISTER FONG YOUR RECORD
AS A MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF HR THIRTY
SEVEN COMMEMORATING THE ONE
HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY.
OF UCLA'S FOUNDING UCLA IS THE
TOP PUBLIC UNIVERSITY UNITED
STATES AS WELL AS WHEN THE TOP
UNIVERSITIES FOR ECONOMIC
MOBILITY.
AND NOT TO MENTION UCLA HAS MORE
NC DOUBLE A TEAM CHAMPIONSHIPS
THE U. S. C..
AS A PROUD GRADUATE OF UCLA
CLASS OF A ONE I WOULD LIKE TO
CONGRATULATE THE UNIVERSITY ON
SUCH A TREMENDOUS ACHIEVEMENT.
GO BRUINS.
THANK YOU MISTER FONG.
MR MURATSUCHI.
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AS A PROUD UCLA BRUIN.
AND AS A JOINT AUTHOR OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
HI [inaudible]
STAND.
TO YOU KNOW.
TALK ABOUT HOW.
WHEN I WENT TO COLLEGE?
WE LIKE TO PLAY WITH THE
INITIALS U. S. C..
LET ME JUST SAY THAT WE ALWAYS
REFERRED TO OUR CROSS TOWN
RIVAL'S AS THE UNIVERSITY OF
PRIVILEGED CHILDREN.
WHEREAS UCLA.
I'M PROUD TO SAY AS ALWAYS BEEN.
THE PEOPLE SCHOOL.
AND I'VE ALWAYS TAKEN SPECIAL
PLEASURE WHENEVER YOU SEE LA
WOULD BEAT USC.
WHERE IT'S IN THE CASE OF
FOOTBALL DOESN'T HAPPEN OFTEN
ENOUGH?
BUT I WANT TO RISE. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT.
THE NUMBER ONE PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
AND THAT WE CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY RESOURCES TO OUR
GREAT UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
SO THAT WE PROTECT THE BRAND
SUPPORT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE CONTINUE
TO LEAD IN THE AREA PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CELIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER YOU
KNOW ITS -- BEEN A PLEASURE TO
ACTUALLY WORK ON THIS WITH THE
AUTHOR.
AS WE TALK ABOUT UCLA AND YOU
KNOW WE JOSH A LOT ABOUT.
USC AND UCLA BUT WHAT THIS
REALLY MEANS.
TO UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIAN
REALLY TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW WHEN THINGS I JUST
WANTED TO POINT OUT THOUGH.
SINCE THE THE AUTHOR MADE IT A
POINT TO TALK ABOUT HER
UNDERGRAD.
IS THE UNIVERSITY TO A HUNDRED
TO A HUNDRED NC DOUBLE A TITLES.
WAS ACTUALLY UCLA.
FIRST UNIVERSITY TWO HUNDRED YOU
SEAL IT TO TO NATIONAL TITLES.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT A LOT
OF MEMBERS HERE PROBABLY DON'T
KNOW.
THERE'S BEEN NINETY TWO MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT ACTUALLY
GRADUATED FROM UCLA AS I WANTED
TO POINT THAT OUT.
BUT I WANTED TO JUST SAY GO
BRUINS OF THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BOOK A CO AUTHOR AND I'M.
PROUD TO SUPPORT HR.
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER
SALAS MS QUIRK SILVA.
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I TOO AM A GRADUATE OF
UCLA BUT I TOOK A DIFFERENT ROAD
THAN SOME OF YOU MIGHT HAVE AS I
WAS A TRANSFER STUDENT -- FROM
FULLERTON COLLEGE TO UCLA.
AND THAT WAS BACK IN THE
EIGHTIES BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE I TRANSFERRED AND
GRADUATED -- AFTER TWO YEARS
TAKING ALMOST TWENTY UNITS
COMING FROM A LARGE FAMILY OF
TEN I DID NOT HAVE
TRANSPORTATION SO I WOULD TAKE
THE AMTRAK. TO DOWNTOWN LA AND
TRANSFERRED TAKE THE BUS ALL THE
WAY UP TO UCLA.
I HAVE MANY FOND MEMORIES BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT REALLY
STRUCK ME AS ONE OF MY JOBS ON
THE CAMPUS OF UCLA WAS WORKING
AT THE WOODEN CENTER.
AND AS I BECAME AN EDUCATOR I
LEARNED MORE AND MORE ABOUT THE
GREAT COACH JOHN WOODEN AND HE
IS -- PYRAMID OF SUCCESS SO
THROUGHOUT MY YEARS OF TEACHING
I TAUGHT MANY OF MY STUDENTS
ABOUT THAT PYRAMID OF SUCCESS
WHICH HAS A CHARACTERISTIC. FOR
EACH UP HERE MATTER EACH SQUARE
ON THE PYRAMID OF CHARACTER OF
FRIEND SHIPPED OF INTEGRITY OF
SKILL OF ACTION AND I KNOW THAT
HAVING THAT EXPERIENCE CHANGED
MY LIFE AND HAS CHANGE THE LIFE
OF MANY OTHERS.
SO A GREAT COACH A GREAT
CHAMPION AND A POET JOHN WOULD
AND IS ONE OF THE MOST HIGHLY
RECOGNIZED COACHES IN CHAMPIONS
AND HIS TEAM IS RIGHT THERE ON
THAT CAMPUS SO WITH THAT GO
BRUINS AND CHECK OUT THE SURE TO
EVERYBODY.
HARD TO FIND.
AN FULLER TEN BUT GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MS QUIRK SILVA MISS
SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE ALSO IS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS
RESOLUTION AND AS A GRADUATE OF
UCLA MYSELF.
I AM PROBABLY THE WIFE OF A
BRUIN AND NOW THE MOTHER OF A
BREWING WHO WILL BE GRADUATING
IN THREE WEEKS SO IT IS A HUGE
HONOR TO ME TO BE ON THE FLOOR
TODAY.
TO CONGRATULATE AND CELEBRATE
WITH MY ALMA MATER A CENTURY OF
SUCCESS WITH THAT I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH.
MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I THANK THE SPEAKER MEMBERS I
YEAH.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS A
RESOLUTION BECAUSE AS A PROUD
FRESNO STATE BULLDOGS.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REGULARLY CONTEST WITH UCLA ON
THE OF FOOTBALL GRIDIRON.
AND I WOULD -- ALSO REMIND
EVERYBODY ON THE FLOOR THAT
FRESNO STATE.
DID IN FACT BEAT UCLA LAST TIME.
AND AND IN FACT.
FRESNO STATE HAD THE BEST
FOOTBALL RECORD OF ANY COLLEGE
IN.
CALIFORNIA.
NOT THAT I NOT THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO RUB IT IN OR IN ANY WAY.
DENIGRATE -- THE WONDERFUL FOLKS
FROM UCLA.
I GO BRUINS.
AND THEN WHEN WE MEET THE WHEN
WE MEET THE BRUINS AGAIN WITH
FRESNO STATE BULLDOGS.
I'M GONNA BE ROOTING. FOR FOR
ANOTHER VICTORY.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO
DO THAT -- BUT AGAIN UCLA IS
REALLY IMPORTANT IT'S GREAT FOR
THE STATE I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
BUT ALSO -- THAT A LITTLE BIT OF
FUN WITH -- THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
ALARMS AT AT AT UCLA JUST TO
REMIND THAT.
THAT.
SCHOOL IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA IS
ALSO THE PEOPLE'S COLLEGE AND
IT'S ALSO PRETTY DOGGONE GOOD
FOOTBALL.
THANK YOU MISS PATTERSON AND
THERE MAY BE TROUBLE BREWING
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED [inaudible]
SO -- ALL RIGHTS TO COMPLEMENT
THE BRUINS. FOR MAKING IT. TO A
CENTURY.
SINCE WE STARTED AT USC IN.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY WE'RE AT A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE YEARS.
HOPEFULLY YOU'LL BE ABLE TO MAKE
IT TO THOSE GRANT [inaudible]
YEARS.
BUT MOST IMPORTANT.
THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
MEMBER OF THIS ASSEMBLY.
IS WHERE UCLA STARTED.
THE FIRST AFTER AMERICAN FRED
ROBERTS [inaudible]
A REPUBLICAN.
AFTER AN AMERICAN.
AND A ALARM OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IS WHERE YOU SEE A LATE FIRST
STARTED THEIR HUMBLE BEGINNINGS
BEGINNINGS AS BABY BEARS BACK IN
THE DAY.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT THE ESEE
UCLA RIVALRY IS LIKE.
ANY RIVALRY YOU'VE SEEN ACROSS
THE COUNTRY OUR RIVALRY IS
CONSIDERED ONE OF THE BEST.
AND RIVALRIES OF WHAT MAKES THIS
NOT ONLY THIS COUNTRY GREAT WHAT
MAKES US GREAT.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN CONTINUE
THAT RIVALRY. TO THE NEXT
CENTURY BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS
WHAT MAKES SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
GREAT.
AND FOR ME. FOR ME I'M WAITING
FOR THAT ONE DAY WHEN THE WHOLE
COUNTRY HATES LOS ANGELES.
BECAUSE S. SEES THE NATIONAL
CHAMPION IN FOOTBALL YOU SALES
NATIONAL CHAMPION BASKETBALL AND
EVERYBODY IN THE COUNTRY'S GONNA
HATE IS ALL.
MR THIS AREA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER -- I
JUST WANT I HAD VERY FEW WORDS
THAT I WANTED TO SHARE BUT I
COULDN'T HELP.
NOTICING THE COMMENTS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM A DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES MADE.
AND WHILE HE WAS SPEAKING ABOUT
HOW IT'S A WONDERFUL RIVALRY --
FOR YOU SILLY IT'S CONSIDERED A
CHARITY SO YOU'RE WELCOME TO
THAT -- BY DEBT ALL JOKES ASIDE
IT'S WONDERFUL TO HAVE TWO
WONDERFUL INSTITUTIONS THAT NOT
ONLY CONTRIBUTE TO THE FABRIC OF
ACADEMICS.
BUT ALSO MAKE SURE THAT FUNDING
CONTINUOUSLY COMES TO THE TO
CALIFORNIA AND TO THE SOUTH LAND.
NOW THAT SAID I JUST WANTED TO
NOT SURE IF -- THE WONDERFUL
GENTLE LADY FROM.
OF LOS ANGELES WHO INTRODUCED A
RESOLUTION SPOKE ABOUT THE
ELEVEN BILLION ANNUAL
CONTRIBUTION THAT ALL THE UC'S
CONTRIBUTE.
AND NOW FOR BILLION OF IT COMES
FROM UCLA BUT JUST AS ECONOMIC
ENGINE HUBS IT'S VERY CRITICAL
FOR US TO LOOK AT THE UC'S AS
WELL AS ARE OTHERS.
ARE ARE CSU STATE SCHOOLS BUT
ESPECIALLY THE UC'S GIVEN THEIR
RESEARCH CAPABILITY THAT THEY
NOT ONLY PROVIDE JOBS NOT ONLY
ARE THEY INVESTMENTS FOR THE
FUTURE BUT THEY'RE ALSO THE
DRIVERS OF TECHNOLOGY THAT
CONTRIBUTE.
GREATLY TO NOT ONLY MEETING OUR
NEEDS IN THE STATE IN HEALTHCARE
EDUCATION WHEREVER CUT WHEREVER
THEY'RE A RESEARCH LEADS BUT
ALSO THE FACT THAT THE DRY THEY
ARE THE ECONOMIC ENGINES.
AND DRIVERS OF TECHNOLOGY THAT
THEN GETS USED WORLDWIDE AND
BRINGS ATTENTION AND ACCOLADES
TO THE STATE SO FOR THAT.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CELEBRATING MANY MORE
YEARS OF UCLA'S ACHIEVEMENTS
HERE AND AND WE'RE EVERYWHERE
ELSE IN THE STATE THANK YOU.
THANK EMISSIONS ARIAN.
MS CARILLO.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SEND
MEMBERS AS A PROUD ALUMNI OF USC.
AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE
BEING HOME TO THE U. S. THE CáC
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
CONGRADULATIONS TO UCLA ON
ACHIEVING THIS MOMENTOUS
MOMENTOUS OCCASION.
I AM VERY PROUD TO BE SUPPORTING
THIS RESOLUTION HR THIRTY SEVEN
UCLA HAS SPEARHEADED THE NATION
AND HAVING.
AND UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
RESOURCE CENTER THAT HAS HELP
STUDENTS ACROSS THE UNIVERSITY
AND SET THE TONE FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL FOR THE
NATION AND FOR THAT.
I COMMEND THE UNIVERSITY THANK
YOU.
THIS GONZALES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M AS
A CO AUTHOR TO THIS RESOLUTION I
WON I THINK THAT MY COLLEAGUE
RING AFFORD I'M A PROUD AT UCLA
LET NINE NOT OFTEN RECOGNIZED AS
SUCH BUT I DID RECEIVE MY LAW
DEGREE FROM UCLA.
AND THAT WITHOUT QUESTION IT IS
THE BEST PUBLIC SCHOOL IN
CALIFORNIA.
PUBLIC SCHOOL.
AND AND THE SECOND BEST SCHOOL
IN THE PAC TWELVE NEXT TO
STANFORD GO BRUINS [inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT.
THAT UCLA HAS SEVEN GRADUATES
WHO HAVE WON NOBEL PRIZES.
AND USC HAS.
NINE THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK.
DOCTOR WEBER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
I TO RISE A DAY IN SUPPORT OF HR
THIRTY SEVEN RECOGNIZING MAY
TWENTY THIRD.
TWENTY NINETEEN AS A HUNDREDTH
ANNIVERSARY OF UCLA'S FOUNDING.
AND I THANK MY COLLEAGUE HERE
FROM LOS ANGELES AND FROM S. C..
OF FOR BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FOR AND I'M PROUD CO AUTHOR OF
IT.
UNLIKE SOME OF YOU -- I DON'T
SIT AROUND AND TALK ABOUT THE
BRUINS AND THE ESEE FOLKS AND
ALL THOSE PEOPLE BECAUSE I'M A
I'M A HIGH I'M IN A HIGHER IT
EDUCATOR.
AND I KNOW THAT ALL OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS ARE EXCELLENT AND
ARE NECESSARY TO PROVIDE THE
KIND OF EDUCATION EXPERIENCE FOR
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M DIFFERENT FROM MOST OF YOU
BECAUSE I'M A TRIPLE BREWING.
I HAVE A BACHELOR'S OR MASTER'S
AND A PHD FROM UCLA.
AND RECEIVE THEM.
RECEIVE THEM BOTH BY THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX AND I SAY THAT
PROBABLY NOT BECAUSE I WAS SOME
PRODIGY CHILD.
BUT BECAUSE CALIFORNIA GAVE ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT.
AND THAT'S THE VALUE OF UCLA.
NOT THE FOOTBALL AND BASKETBALL
AND ALL THOSE THINGS WE GET
CAUGHT UP IN.
BUT THE FACT THAT THIS STATE
DECIDED TO DEVELOP THE
UNIVERSITY IS A CALIFORNIA. TO
BE A COUNTER TO THE PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS THAT THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIAN COULDN'T AFFORD.
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE S. SEASON WE
HAVE THE STAMFORD TO WE HAVE
THOSE PLACES BUT THEY WERE ALL
DESIGNED FOR THE ELITE.
AND SO CALIFORNIA DECIDED IN ITS
WISDOM TO DEVELOP A UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM.
THAT WOULD BE COMPETITIVE WITH
THE PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS. TO
PROVIDE AN EDUCATION FOR THE
EVERY CHILD AND WHEN YOU READ
THE PREAMBLE OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA YOU SEE THAT THAT
THAT IT'S IT'S MISSION.
AND I TAKE PRIDE IN THE FACT
THAT BEING A POOR KID FROM SOUTH
CENTRAL LA.
THAT I COULD GO TO ONE OF THE
FINEST INSTITUTIONS IN THE WORLD.
GET DEGREES FROM THAT
INSTITUTION THAT WOULD OPEN
DOORS FOR ME THAT I HAD NEVER
IMAGINED MYSELF.
AND THAT IS WHAT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S ABOUT.
THAT IS WHAT YOU SEE LA IS ABOUT
THAT IT REALLY GIVES EVERY
CALIFORNIANS EVERY CHILD
OPPORTUNITY TO BE EXCELLENT.
THAT IS TRULY THE AMERICAN
EQUALIZER.
AND CALIFORNIA'S SHOULD BE PROUD
OF THAT.
AND THE FACT THAT ONE OF ITS
INSTITUTIONS UCLA ALONG
OBVIOUSLY WOULD BERKELEY AS WELL
AS REALLY DISTINGUISH ITSELF NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT AROUND THE WORLD WE SHOULD
BE VERY PROUD.
AND WE SHOULD BE VERY COMMITTED
TO MAINTAINING OUR INSTITUTIONS
FOR OUR CHILDREN FOR THE EVERY
CHILD IN CALIFORNIA.
I TAKE PRIDE IN THE FACT THAT I
HAVE THREE DEGREES WHEN YOU SEE
A WAY.
AND I GRADUATED OWING A DEBT OF
TWELVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS.
THAT'S UCLA.
THAT'S THE CALIFORNIA DREAM THAT
IS WHAT WE SHOULD BE STRIVING
FOR SO THAT WE DON'T END UP IN
IN DEBT WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO
BUILD A LIFE AND IT GIVES US THE
OPPORTUNITY THEN TO WORK. TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE COMMUNITY
WITHOUT THE TREMENDOUS DEBT THAT
WE SEE YOUNG PEOPLE HAVING TODAY.
MOST OF US PROBABLY SAW THE WHAT
HAPPENED AND MORE HOUSES WEEKEND.
WHEN ONE OF OUR BLACK
BILLIONAIRES DECIDED TO CANCEL
THE DEBT OF EVERY STUDENT WHO IS
A GRADUATE OF MOREHOUSE OVER
FOUR HUNDRED STUDENTS?
WHAT A GIFT WHAT AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE TO
BASICALLY BEGIN TO LIVE THEIR
LIVES AND I CAN UNDERSTAND THAT
BECAUSE IN MANY WAYS THAT WAS
GIVEN TO ME BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA?
SO I CELEBRATE THE HUNDRED YEARS
OF UCLA AS A GREAT INSTITUTION
AND YOU CAN READ ABOUT ALL OF
ITS NOBEL PRIZE WINNERS YOU CAN
READ ABOUT ALL OF THOSE THINGS
THAT IT IS DONE ALL OF ITS
RESEARCH GRANTS ALL OF ITS IN
DOWN MIX.
ALL THAT STUFF IS ABSOLUTELY
AMAZING.
BUT IN THE END IT BOILS DOWN TO
BE.
A LITTLE GIRL FROM THE PUEBLOS
OF LOS ANGELES WHO LIVED IN THE
PROJECTS.
WHO WENT TO SCHOOL DADDY TOLD HE
WOULD DRINK MUDDY WATER AND
SLEEP IN A HOLLOW LOG IF YOU
WANT TO GO TO SCHOOL?
MAKING A COMMITMENT TO HER TO BE
EXCELLENT.
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BEFORE THERE WAS ANY
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT ADMITTED
ME TO THE INSTITUTION.
WITH A BIT WITH THE ABILITY TO
HAVE A SCHOLARSHIPS AND GRANTS
THAT BEEN MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR
ME TO CONTINUE TO GO TO SCHOOL
FROM ONE DEGREE TO THE NEXT.
AND END UP AS A UNIVERSITY
PROFESSOR ONE OF THE WOODROW
WILSON FELLOWS AT THE TIME.
AND TEACH AT THE UNIVERSITY FOR
FORTY YEARS AND BE ABLE TO GIVE
BACK TO CALIFORNIA WHAT IT IS
GIVEN TO ME.
THAT IS UCLA THAT IS WHAT WE
THINK ABOUT THAT IS WHAT WE
DREAM ABOUT AND THAT IS WHAT WE
CELEBRATE TODAY THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THAT THE WEBER.
I WOULD JUST REQUEST THAT WE
REFRAIN FROM.
APERTURE APPLAUSE DURING DEBATE
ON AN ITEM BEFORE THIS HOUSE MR
SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU WANT.
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION UP AND
CHALLENGE SOME OF THE COMMENTS
OF IT MADE BECAUSE THE BEST
THING ABOUT THE RIVALRY RIVALRY
AND LOS ANGELES IS THAT UCLA'S A
BETTER SCHOOL.
HANDS DOWN NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
AND WHAT ONE SCHOOL ACHIEVED A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE YEARS
WE'VE WAITED SIR PASSED AND LESS
THAN A HUNDRED YEARS SO ON
BEHALF OF THE SEVEN NOBEL PEACE
PRIZE WINNERS.
WE HAVE ALL THE ALONE NICE ALL
THE ALUMS HERE ON THE ON THE
FLOOR WE WANT TO REQUEST THE
STRONG BY THIS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR THIS RESOLUTION
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE RESOLUTION MS
KAMLAGER-DOVE YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES -- FOR RISING TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF UCLA THOSE
WHO ARE ALARM OF UCLA MY FELLOW
TROJANS AND THOSE WHO'VE GONE TO
OTHER SCHOOLS -- I STARTED BY
SAYING.
UCLA CAME INTO EXISTENCE.
AGAINST A NUMBER OF ODDS AND IT
TOOK RISKS TO PUSH BEYOND THE
RESISTANCE TO BE CALM THE
PRESTIGIOUS SCHOOL.
THAT IT IS TODAY AND IT WILL
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO TAKE RISKS
TO STAY NUMBER ONE AS A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY.
IT WILL HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
ENROLL MORE.
GRADUATE MORE.
ALL WHILE FINDING WAYS TO REDUCE
COSTS WITH OUT SACRIFICING ITS
EXCELLENCE AND I KNOW THAT THAT
CAN BE DONE AND BASED ON THE
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR FOR THIS
RESOLUTION.
I BELIEVE THAT WE ALL WILL HELP
UCLA CONTINUE TO MEET THOSE
CHALLENGES.
HR THIRTY SEVEN IS CERTAINLY
ABOUT CELEBRATING THE CENTENNIAL
OF UCLA BUT IT IS ALSO ABOUT RE
COMMITTING OURSELVES TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE MASTER PLAN OF
EDUCATION.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE MAKE
PUBLIC EDUCATION HIGH QUALITY.
ACCESSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE.
THROUGH K. THROUGH TWELVE ALL
THE WAY THROUGH COLLEGE.
WE WERE THE GOLDEN STATE
PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF OUR
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
MOST OF WHICH WE WERE SUPPORTING
WERE PUBLIC.
WE CERTAINLY SHOULD NOT CONTINUE
TO MOVE FARTHER AND FARTHER AWAY
FROM OUR COMMITMENT TO THE
MASTER PLAN.
AND ONCE AGAIN I CANNOT BELIEVE
I'M SAYING THIS AS A TROJAN TURN
BRO GIN BUT I AM URGING ALL. TO
VOTE I ON HR THIRTY SEVEN AND TO
WORK WITH ME TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE PUTTING OUR PUBLIC.
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER LEARNING
A PRIORITY THANK YOU.
IN HIS KAMLAGER-DOVE OF WOULD
YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS KAMLAGER-DOVE REQUEST IN
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS MEMBERS CLICK OPEN ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON H. R. THIRTY SEVEN THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL THEIR
SEVEN EIGHT ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
AND MSKAMLAGER-DOVE OF I RETURN
TO YOU.
YOU'LL BE ADDRESSING THE
ASSEMBLY FROM MY DESK IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER FOR YOUR
SPECIAL.
GUESTS INTRODUCTION AND
PRESENTATION.
MAYES KAMLAGER-DOVE YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SO I AM
HERE IF IF.
YOU HAVEN'T GUESSEDWE HAVE A
NUMBER OF ATTENDEES.
AT IN THE BACK AND ALSO IN THE
GALLERY FROM UCLA WE HAVE OUR
PROVOST -- SCOTT ONE AND I THINK
WE ALSO HAVE THE AMAZING JANICE
CAITLYN -- HASHI HERE AMONG
OTHERS I'M TO CELEBRATE.
THE CENTENNIAL OF UCLA AND SO WE
WILL BE TAKING PHOTOS IN THE
BACK I AM REQUESTING THAT CO
AUTHORS THE LINES.
OF UCLA JOIN US IN THE BACK FOR
A PHOTO AND WE MADE SURE THAT WE
PUT TOGETHER A RESOLUTION WITH
MY FAVORITE COLORS. TO MARK THE
OCCASION.
OF THIS AND SENATE.
SO WE WILL TAKE IT.
WITH THIS RESOLUTION AND THEN I
HAVE ANOTHER ONE IN CASE FOLKS
JUST CAN'T STOMACH IT
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
GUEST WITH US IN THE GALLERY AND
IN THE REAR THE CHAMBER MISTER
LEVINE I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A
GUEST GROUP THAT HAS ARRIVED IN
THE GALLERY MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE
ATTENTION THIS LEVINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS IT IS A A
PLEASURE FOR ME TO WELCOME
THIRTY HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS FROM
MARIN COUNTY FROM THE CANAL
ALLIANCE YOU ARE ALL UP THERE'S
A WAVE AND SAY HI EVERYONE.
THESE ARE A GREAT GROUP ISSUES
THE CHILD FROM ALL OVER MY
DISTRICT TO PARTICIPATE.
IN THE IMMIGRANT DAY OF ACTION
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WELCOME
MEAN THE CANAL LINE STUDENTS ARE
HERE WITH US THANKS GUYS FOR
BEING HERE
.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE THIRTEEN THAT IS A C. R.
SEVENTY THREE BY MR BIGELOW
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BIGELOW RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
FAIRGROUNDS APPRECIATION MONTH.
MR BIGELOW YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ACR SEVENTY THREE WHICH
DESIGNATES THE MONTH OF MAY AS
CALIFORNIA FAIRGROUND
APPRECIATION MONTH.
THEIR SEASON IS HERE.
MOST OF THE TIME WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT OUR FARES WE THINK ABOUT
THE RIDES THE GAME SO HORSE
RACING AND THE DELICIOUS FOOD.
HOWEVER.
AND I DO MEAN HOWEVER ARE
SEVENTY EIGHT FAIRS MEANS SO
MUCH MORE TO OUR COMMUNITIES
THAN FRIED OREOS AND ROLLER
COASTERS.
FAIR GROUNDS PROVIDE A CRUCIAL
OPEN SPACE FOR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE SITUATIONS.
THEY ARE VITAL STAGING AREAS FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS DURING
EMERGENCIES.
THEY ARE UTILIZED AS SAFE HAVEN
DURING A CATASTROPHIC DISASTER
SUCH AS A WILDFIRE AND
EARTHQUAKES.
OUR LOCAL FAIRS ARE WHERE WE IN
OUR YOUTH PREPARE TO BECOMETHE
NEXT GENERATION OF FARMERS
RANCHERS.
AND EVEN CREATIVE ARTISTS
[inaudible]
MY FRIENDS.
OUTSIDE OF OUR SUMMER FARES
THESE FAIRGROUNDS HOST CHARITY
EVENTS CONCERTS COMPETITIVE
EXHIBITS AND CULTURAL EVENTS
ALONG WITH MANY WEDDINGS.
HELD OVER A SEVENTEEN DAY PERIOD
THE DAILY ATTENDANCE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FAIR LAST YEAR
RANGE FROM 200-002-60000 PEOPLE
PER DAY.
OUR FAIRGROUNDS BENEFIT THE
LOCAL ECONOMIES CREATE A RIPPLE
EFFECT OF ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND OPPORTUNITY FOR TOURISM
DOLLARS FOR THE STATE.
LAST YEAR FAIR GORE SPENT EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON
FOOD AND DRINKS ALONE.
FAIRS ALSO GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HONOR OUR
MILITARY AND THOSE WHO HAVE
FALLEN.
LAST YEAR THE NAVY WAS HONORED
THAT FOR THE FIRST FULL WEEK OF
LAST YEAR STATE FAIR.
MEMBERS THESE FACILITIES ARE
WHERE WE MAKE CHERISHED MEMORIES.
WE MUST ENSURE OUR FAIRGROUNDS
RECEIVE THE FUNDING THEY NEED TO
ADDRESS THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND CONTINUE TO BE USED FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME.
I STRONGLY URGE ALL MY
COLLEAGUES TO ATTEND THEIR LOCAL
FAIRS THIS SEASON AND ENJOY ALL
THAT THE FAIR GROUNDS HAVE TO
OFFER.
MISTER SPEAKER IN MEMBERS I WANT
TO THANK YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS MISTER
SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW MISTER
DALLI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I WOULD JUST WANT TO ALSO LET MY
SUPPORT TO THIS RESOLUTION --
SOMEBODY WHO HAS NINE COUNTY
FAIRS AND TO DISTRICT FAIRS ALSO
WANTED JUST TO EXPAND A LITTLE
BIT ON HOW IMPORTANT THOSE FAIR
GROUNDS WERE -- DURING THE
CAMPFIRE AND THE CAR FIRE LAST
YEAR WE HAD THE FACILITIES
AVAILABLE TO BRING LILY
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AND GIVE
THEM SERVICES AND HELP THEM --
THROUGH A ROUTE SOME VERY
DIFFICULT TIMES I ALSO WANT TO
SHARE THAT TO A FEW YEARS BACK
THERE WAS A STUDY DONE.
BY THE AMOUNT OF TAX BASE THAT
FAIRS ACTUALLY GENERATE TO AS
SALES TAX TO THE STATE FUNDS
IT'S A LOT MORE THAN WHAT WE
ACTUALLY SPENT ON FAIRS -- SO --
I WOULD LIKE THAT KEEP THAT MINE
IS LEGISLATORS LOOK AT THE
BUDGET.
AND MAKE SURE WE CAN KEEP THOSE
FACILITIES.
HEALTHY AND AND THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THAT NEED TO BE
TAKEN CARE OF AGAIN I STAND WITH
THE FAIR MANAGERS OR HERE AND
ALSO -- AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
A C. R..
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU MISTER
ALI.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE RESOLUTION.
MR BIGELOW IS ASKING OF THE
FIRST ROLL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS WITH THAT CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
VERSUS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR
[inaudible]
SEVENTY THREE CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SEVENTY CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MISTER BIGELOW.
I RETURN TO YOU FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION RELATIVE TO THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
FIRST I'D LIKE TO COMPLIMENT MY
FELLOW MEMBER FROM THE NORTH
REPRESENTS NINE OF COUNTIES WITH
NINE COUNTY FAIRS AYE TO
REPRESENT NINE COUNTIES.
NOT AS MANY FAIRS NOT
NECESSARILY BECAUSE I TO THE
SMALLEST COUNTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THEY ENJOY A GREAT.
SPIRIT OF CAMARADERIE I WANTED
TO EXPLAIN TO ALL THIS LAST
WEEKEND TO THOSE BEARS WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO COMPLETE THEIR FULL RUN.
AND AS WE ALL KNOW THE WEATHER
BECAUSE THIS TO HAPPEN.
THOSE ARE TO AFFAIRS OF THE MOST.
NEXT FAIRS IN THE STATE BECAUSE
THERE THE STAGING AREAS SO WITH
THE MAJOR PORTION OF THEIR
FINDING LOST.
THROUGH THE RUN OF THE FAIR THIS
WILL MAKE IT CHALLENGING SO
LET'S KEEP THAT THOSE FAIRS AND
MINE.
ON THE FLOOR WITH ME TODAY I
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE THE MEMBERS
TO COME AND ENJOY.
THE FAIR FOOD.
FROM THE FAIR BOARD MEMBERS FROM
AROUND THE STATE HOSTED BY THE
WESTERN FAIRS ASSOCIATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE FAIR UPON A
GERMAN.
RIGHT HERE IN OUR WILLIE BROWN
ROOM AS YOU ALL KNOW EACH YEAR
WE POSTED THIS AND EVERYONE
ENJOYS TO HAVE SOME OF THE
NACHOS THE CINNAMON ROLLS THE
COTTON CANDY AND ALL THE GREAT
FOOD.
AND LASTLY.
UP IN THE BACK OF THE ROOM I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE AND GIVE
A BIG WELCOME AND I WOULD LIKE
ALL OF YOU TO PLEASE JOIN ME.
IN RECOGNIZING MISS PATRICIA
pTHERE'S ASSOCIATION.
CLIFF MONTHS AND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FAIRS ASSOCIATION
HE'S A LIAISON HERE TODAY
ANALYSTS.
WAX TEAM MANAGER THE WESTERN
FAIRS ASSOCIATION.
ALONG WITH.
ALONG WITH -- SERRA CUMMINGS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
WESTERN FAIRS ASSOCIATION AND
GOSH -- I MISSING HERE --
PATRICIA CAUGHT NO I SAID
PROJECT JUDY CORRECT ALL PRESENT
OTHER WESTERN CIVILIZATION I
THINK I MISSED THOSE TOO WELL.
ANYWAY IT'S CLOSE JUDY IS WITH
THE PRESIDENT WHETHER FAIRS
ASSOCIATION AND PATRICIA IS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY WE ENJOY YOU BEING
HERE PLEASE GIVE THEM A WARM
WELCOME.
AND RICK IS HERE ON THE STAGE
HERE I DIDN'T HAVE THEM IN THE
STREET THANK
.
AND MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE FOURTEEN AC ARE SEVENTY
NINE BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY NINE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ IT RELATIVE TO
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES WEEK.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ACR
SEVENTY NINE RECOGNIZES MAY
TWENTIETH THROUGH MAY.
TWENTY SIX AS EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES WE CAN CALIFORNIA.
YEAH MESS WEEK IS A NATIONAL
CAMPAIGN DEDICATED TO
PROFESSIONALS WHO PROVIDE
LIFESAVING CARE TO OTHERS AND
THE TIME OF NEED.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO OVER
EIGHTY THOUSAND CAREER
INVOLUNTARY BOLLINGER.
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICE
PERSONNEL WHO TREAT OVER TWO
MILLION CALIFORNIA'S A YEAR.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN AN
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TECHNICIAN FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS I CAN ATTEST
TO THE TRUE PROFESSIONALISM AND
PASSION THESE INDIVIDUALS BRING
TO THEIR WORK.
WORKING LONG HOURS AND MISSING
SPECIAL MOMENTS WITH FAMILIES
AND FRIENDS AND PUT IN THEIR OWN
LIVES IN THE LINE IS JUST PART
OF THE JOB.
DUE TO THE RECENT FIRES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA OUR EMS PERSONNEL HAD
TO FACE AN EVEN BIGGER CHALLENGE.
MANY LIVES WERE LOST BUT THEIR
SERVICE AND BRAVERY BRAVERY WILL
NEVER BE FORGOTTEN.
THIS RESOLUTION COMMANDS ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS FOR THEIR
SACRIFICE AND DEDICATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THAT
THE FIRST ROW BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS
.
DAVIS RODRIGUEZ SEEING NO
DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION.
IS RODRIGUEZ YOU WOULD LIKE AT
FIRST ROLE TO BE FOR CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
THE CARPAL OF THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CO AUTHOR OF A NAY C.
R..
SEVENTY NINE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSER ALL THEIR
SEVENTY TWO CO AUTHORS AT A
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE AT THAT RESOLUTIONS
ADOPTED A MISTER RODRIGUEZ FOR
YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
MEMBERS TODAY WE JOIN IN THE
GALLERY BY SOME SPECIAL GUESTS.
WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM CAL
FIRE LOCAL FORTY NINE ELEVEN THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
THE MERCY NURSES ASSOCIATION
SACRAMENTO FILED YOUR LOCAL.
FIVE TWENTY TWO THE ALBUM'S
SOCIALIZATION.
AND THE AMERICAN RED CROSS. TO
MY RIGHT PLEASE JOIN ME IN
GIVING THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
THANK YOU.
A MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
IN THE CHAMBER MS Là MON.
I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE YOU FROM
MY DESK IN THERE OF THE CHAMBER
MISSILE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM
HONORED TO HAVE THIS OPPOSITE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE OUR
OUTGOING COMMISSIONER OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT AND IS MISS
JANET LYNN -- IN.
WITH BEAUTIFUL OF SIX I HAVE FOR
HER YEARS OF PUBLIC SERVICE IN
THE FINANCIAL SERVICES ARENA.
AS I CAME INTO MY ROLE AS CHAIR
OF BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
I WAS ENCOURAGED. TO MEET A
FELLOW ONE MAN WITH A LEADERSHIP
ROLE IN THIS SPACE.
IT IS NOT LOST ON EITHER ONE OF
US.
THAT TOO OFTEN WE FIND OURSELVES
IN MEETINGS WITH FIT IN WITH
BUSINESSES AND REPRESENTATIVES
WHERE WE ARE THE ONLY WOMEN AT
THE TABLE.
BUT THAT NEVER KEPT JAN FROM
STANDING UP FOR WHAT'S RIGHT FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
AS OUR STATE CHIEF FINANCIAL
REGULATOR JAN HAS NOT HESITATED
TO TAKE ON HARD ISSUES.
SHE HAS BEEN A STRONG ADVOCATE
FOR CONSUMERS WHO HAVE BEEN
TREATED UNFAIRLY BY LENDERS AND
CHECK CAPTURES RESULTING IN
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN PENALTIES
AND REFUND THAT HAVE GONE BACK.
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS.
HE HAS ALSO BEEN A FAIR AND
REASONABLE REGULATOR INFORMED BY
HER.
EXPERIENCE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
FOR JANET LOVES PUBLIC POLICY
AND LOVED WORKING WITH IN OUR
POLITICAL SYSTEM TO MAKE
POSITIVE CHANGES FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING
AND THINKING GEN LANE -- IN FOR
HER SIXTEEN YEARS OF PUBLIC
SERVICE AND DYNAMIC LEADERSHIP
AS OUR STATE FIRST COMMISSIONER
OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT
JUST A
QUICK NOTE THAT BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE WILL BE
NOW MEETING IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN IF YOU'RE A MEMBER OF
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE.
FIVE YOU WILL NOW BE MEETING IN
ROOM
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL GUEST IN THE CHAMBER
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FONG AND SALAS WE'LL
START WITH MR SALAS.
YOU BOTH HAVE A GUEST GROUP HERE
MISTER SOUTH YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS -- PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING WHO HAVE
BEEN SITTING UP IN THE GALLERY
VERY PATIENTLY.
STUDENTS FROM BAKERSFIELD
COLLEGE.
UP HERE IN THE GALLERY TO OUR
LAST -- THESE ARE STUDENTS WE
ACTUALLY GOT TO SPEND SOME TIME
WITH THIS MORNING AND ACTUALLY
LEARN ABOUT SOME OF THE RULES
WHAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISHING.
AS WAS A THANK YOU GUYS FOR
JOINING US THIS IS YOUR BUILDING.
AND THE GOVERNMENT YOU'RE DEL
HELP EACH AND EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THESE TO THANK YOU GUYS FOR
BEING HERE AND FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
AND MR BARNEY WERE ALSO
RECOMMENDS.
I THINK IT IS A SPEAKER IS ALSO
MY PLEASURE TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUE
TO RECOGNIZE THIS IS A BIGGER
COLLEGE OF IS IN THE CAPITAL AND
THE OTHER TODAY -- IT IS
EXCITING TO SEE YOUNG STUDENTS
HERE LEARNING ABOUT THE
GOVERNMENT LEARNING BY THE
PUBLIC POLICY PROCESS AND WE
CERTAINLY WELCOME THEM HERE THE
CAPITAL SO.
AGO GATES AND WE ARE BC.
AND MR MAYES YOU HAVE GUESTS
HERE TODAY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER.
A COLLEAGUES IT IS MY PRIVILEGE
TO WELCOME OF THE GREATER
COACHELLA VALLEY CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND NEARLY TWENTY LOCAL
CAPITAL TODAY TO ADVOCATE FOR
OUR REGION.
OF YOU GUYS STAND.
SO IF YOU GUYS COULD JOIN ME IN
OFFERING THEM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE AND WISH THEM WELL IN
THEIR ENDEAVORS AS THEY ADVOCATE
FOR THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
THE TOP OF THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE.
FILE ITEMS FOR FIFTY THROUGH FOR
FIFTY FIVE PASSED RETAIN.
WHAT A PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM?
FOR FIFTY SIX FILE ITEM.
FOR FIFTY SEVEN THIS IS MISS
BURKE AB NINE TWENTY TWO CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE AND
ACTUALLY TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
MS BURKE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB NINE TWENTY TWO PROMOTES
MEDICAL RESEARCH IN CALIFORNIA
WHILE ENSURING RESEARCH
PARTICIPANTS ARE FAIRLY TREATED.
BY REMOVING THE PROHIBITION ON
COMPENSATION FOR WOMEN
PARTICIPATING IN EGG DONATION
FOR MEDICAL RESEARCH.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT WOMEN ARE
TREATED EQUAL TO ALL OF THE
RESEARCH SUBJECTS ALLOWING THEM
TO ACTIVELY EVALUATE THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN RESEARCH
STUDIES AND BE PAID FOR THEIR
TIME.
TROUBLE AND INCONVENIENCE WHEN
THEY DO PARTICIPATE REMOVING THE
BAN ON COMPENSATION ALLOWS A
DONOR'S JUST LIKE ANY OTHER
RESEARCH PARTICIPANT TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION ON
PARTICIPATION AND BE A PROPERLY
COMPENSATED I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN IRA.
THANK YOU MS BURKE SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF IT IS AT ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL ANTI ABOUT ICE FIFTY
FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM.
FOR FIFTY EIGHT FILE ITEM FOR
FIFTY NINE PASS RETAIN.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM.
FOR SIXTY AB SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE
BY MISTER BONTA [inaudible]
CORPORATION.
A SINGLE SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE WITH
THE MEMONS BY FAMILY MEMBER
BONTA.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT A
MEMBERS THE A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY
NINE THESE AMENDMENTS STRIKE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT WOULD
HAVE ALLOWED THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. TO RAISE THE DEALER
RECORD OF SALE FEE KNOWN AS THE
GROSS PHOEBE ON THE CONSUMER
PRICE INDEX.
ADDITIONALLY THESE AMENDMENTS
LIMIT THE COSTS THE DRONES FUND
CAN BE USED.
FOR I WOULD LIKE TO THINK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM ENSURE CORDOVA
AND THOUSAND OAKS AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THIS BODY FOR THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
THAT WILL MAKE THIS A STRONGER
BILL I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
THESE AMENDMENTS BE ADOPTED.
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING THOSE
AMENDMENTS MISTER BONTA.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILLS OUT OF PRINT.
AND BACK ON FILE FILE ITEMS FOR
SIXTY ONE THROUGH.
FOUR SIXTY FOUR PASS AND RETAIN
[inaudible]
WE ARE.
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON DOCTOR WOODS AMENDMENTS.
WHERE PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM?
FOR SIXTY FIVE WE'RE FILE ITEM.
FOR SIXTY SIX AB NINE TWELVE
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE TWELVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO MARINE
INVASIVE SPECIES.
SURE MURATSUCHI YOU MAY I THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I PRESENT AB
NINE TWELVE THE BILL THAT IS
SPONSORED BY THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION THAT WOULD ALLOW.
THE LANDS COMMISSION THE
CONTINUE TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
OCEAN ECOSYSTEM BY FIGHTING THE
INTRODUCTION A MARINE INVASIVE
SPECIES INTO OUR WATERS.
THIS IS -- RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND THE COMMITTEES HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
AMOS MURATSUCHI.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
COR CLUB IN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CULTURAL TELL EITHER BUT I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
RETURN TO FILE ITEM.
FOR SIXTY FIVE THAT IS AB
SEVENTEEN TEN FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS COOKERY WITH
AMENDMENTS.
AS AN ABLE SEVENTEEN TEN WITH
THE MEMONS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
WOULD.
DOCTOR WITH THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ARE RISE PERCENT AMENDMENTS IS
AB SEVENTEEN TEN THESE ARE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT OUR PREVIOUS MO YOU BY THE
COUNTY OF DEL NORTE.
AND THE UP ALLEY RANCHERIAS
RECOGNIZE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE AYES
HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED.
BILLS OUT TO PRINTED BACK ON
FILE FILE ITEMS FOR SIXTY SEVEN
AND FOUR SIXTY EIGHT ASCERTAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM?
FOR SIXTY NINE THIS IS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS QUICK READ
WITH THE MEMONS.
A SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ONE WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING
MEMBER BONTA [inaudible]
MR BONTA.
ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ONE ON JUST BECAUSE EVICTIONS.
THESE AMENDMENTS MERCH AB SIXTY
NINETY SEVEN AUTHORED BY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM CONCORD AND AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE INTO AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM CONCORD WILL BE
THE LEAD JOINT AUTHOR.
AND I WILL BE THE OTHER JOINT
AUTHOR THESE AMENDMENTS AT A SIX
MONTH VESTING PERIOD BEFORE ANY
JUST CAUSE PROTECTIONS GO INTO
EFFECT.
THIS WILL ALLOW LANDLORDS AMPLE
TIME TO EVALUATE THEIR TENANTS
ADDITIONALLY THESE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THE RELOCATION
ASSISTANCE WILL BE ISSUED IN THE
AMOUNT OF TWO MONTHS RENT FOR
ELIGIBLE TENANTS THAT HAVE LIVED
IN THE UNIT FROM SIX MONTHS TO
LESS THAN TWO YEARS AND THREE
MONTHS RENT. FOR THOSE THAT HAVE
LIVED IN THE UNIT FOR TWO OR
MORE YEARS IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERN REGARDING SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES THESE AMENDMENTS
EXEMPT.
OWNERS OF FOUR OR LESS SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES FROM HAVING TO
PROVIDE ANY RELOCATION
ASSISTANCE FINALLY THESE MOMENTS
ADD A TEN YEAR SUNSET DATE. TO
THE BILL I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CONCORD FOR HIS
DEDICATION AND THIS PARTNERSHIP
ON THIS BILL AND STAKEHOLDERS
FOR THEIR INPUT THAT LED. TO
THESE AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT THESE AMENDMENTS BE
ADOPTED.
AMOS BOTTOM IS GRAYSON THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER CALLING I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE AMENDMENTS TO AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE I AM PROUD
TO BE JOINT AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM OPEN.
AND THESE AMENDMENTS ARE A
PRODUCT OF EXTENSIVE NEGOTIATION
WAS STAKEHOLDERS ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE ISSUE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
THANK RESTORATION SEE NOTICED
CATCHER DEBATE AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION AND WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILLS OUT TO PRINT.
IN BACK ON FILE FILE ITEM FOR
SEVENTY PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM FOR SEVENTY ONE IS A.
B. TWELVE EIGHTY SIX BY MISTER
MURATSUCHI CORKERY.
AS I'M ABLE TWELVE EIGHTY SIX BY
SOMEONE MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
ACTUALLY THE MOBILITY DEVICES.
THIS MURATSUCHI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PRESENTING.
THE E. SCOOTERS AN E. BIKES
PUBLIC SAFETY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION BILL.
WE HAVE SEEN EASE CODERS AN E.
BIKES SOMETIMES APPEARING
OVERNIGHT.
YEAH I IN IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THEY CAN BE FUN AFFORDABLE ECO
FRIENDLY WAYS TO GET AROUND.
HOWEVER WE'RE SEEING A GROWING
PROBLEM IN MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH WRITERS LEAVING
EASE SCOOTERS EVERYWHERE LIVING
A MASS LEAVING A HAZARD
ESPECIALLY FOR THE DISABLED AND
THE SENIORS.
AND WITH WRITERS WRITING AND
PARKING ON SIDEWALKS.
AB TAUGHT TWELVE EIGHTY SIX IS
PROPOSING A SOLUTION I HAVE A
WORK OF BEEN WORKING WITH.
THE SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL
INCLUDING THE LEGAL CALIFORNIA
CITIES DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AN ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AS WELL AS THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL THE CONSUMER
TURN IS A CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE ALSO BEEN WORKING.
AND TAKING A LOT OF AMENDMENTS
TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION.
I FIRST TO REMOVE THE
PROHIBITION ON MANDATORY
ARBITRATION WHICH NOT ONLY
REMOVE THIS BILL FROM THE CAL
CHAMBER JOB KILLER LIST BUT IT'S
ALSO REMOVED THE CAL CHAMBERS.
OPPOSITION SO THEY ARE NOW
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL.
SECOND I CLARIFIED I ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT USER CONDUCT
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROVIDERS OF
SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES ARE NOT
LIABLE FOR DRUNK A RECKLESS
DRIVER WRITERS.
AND THIRD I LOWERED THE MINIMUM
LIABILITY INSURANCE A PROVISION
FROM FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO ONE
MILLION DOLLARS PER OCCURRENCE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM QUIRK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ADAMO.
ALL MEMBERS WILL RESERVE VOTE
VOTERS OUT OF A
ALL MEMBERS
ABOUT [inaudible]
MR MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
THIS MURATSUCHI.
MOVES A CALL
.
FILE ITEMS. FOR SEVENTY TWO
THREE FOUR SEVENTY FOUR PASS AND
RETAIN FILE OUT OF FOUR SEVENTY
FIVE A. B.. FIVE TWENTY THREE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CORKERY WITH AMENDMENTS AS
UNABLE FIVE TWENTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY FAMILY MEMBER OR
WHEN -- WHAT ON THE MINUTES GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS ON -- AB
FIVE TWO THREE THESE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS DRAFTING AMBIGUITIES
REYES BY THE PRIVACY COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS AND ADDRESS CONCERNS
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ABOUT
BEING ABLE TO ACCESS APPROPRIATE
RECORDS TAUGHT AT THEIR UTILITY
PROGRAMS.
SPECS WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER ONE SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT.
THE MEMBERS ARE NOT THE BILL'S
AT SPRINT BACK ON FILE.
FILE ITEMS FOR SEVENTY SIX TO
FORTY ONE PASS RETAIN.
WHAT A PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM?
FORTY TWO FILE ITEM FOR EIGHTY
THREE IS AB ONE SEVENTY NINE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CLERK
WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
IS RAISE THE MOMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TO
THEIR PRESENT AMENDMENTS AB ONE
SEVENTY NINE A BILL THAT MAKES
CHANGES TO THE FRANCHISE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CALIFORNIA.
NEW CAR DEALERS AND AUTOMAKERS
THESE AMENDMENTS REPRESENT THE
CULMINATION OF STAKEHOLDER
DISCUSSIONS INVOLVING THE
OPPOSITION SPONSORS AND TO MY
OFFICE.
I WOULD LIKE TO PARTICULARLY
THANK THE CHAIR TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE FOR HIS EFFORTS TO
BRINGING ALL THE PARTIES. TO THE
TABLE.
I ALSO FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS SO WE CAN GET
OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
THERE WAS REYES SAY NO
DISCUSSION.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE MOMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY YES HAVE IT.
IT'S OUR JOB TO THE BILLS OUT OF
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE FILE ITEM.
FORTY FOUR IS AB THIRTEEN OH
FOUR BY MISS WALDRON THE
CORPORATION.
AS A LEGAL THIRTEEN OH FOUR BY
SELLING MEMBER WALDRON AND I
CLEAN WATER.
WATER YOU MAIL BUT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS A SIMPLE
BILL TWO YEARS AGO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM COACHELLA I RAN A BILL AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE THAT ALLOWED
WATER DISTRICTS TO SERVICE
TRIBAL LANDS THIS BILL AB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR ALLOWS THE
WATER DISTRICT. TO CONTRACT AND
RECEIVE WATER DELIVERIES FROM AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS ON
TRIBAL LANDS.
BY ALLOWING WATER DISTRICTS TO
RECEIVE WATER DELIVERIES.
FROM INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS ON
TRIBAL LANDS THIS BILL IS A
HELPFUL SUPPLY SIDE SOLUTION TO
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL WATER. TO
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
I'M SORRY RESTAURANTS.
YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES ON AS A
CHAIR OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS ARISES
SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTEEN OH FOUR I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ESCONDIDO FOR
AUTHORING THIS BILL.
THIS BILL GIVES TRIBES ANOTHER
POSSIBLE REVENUE SOURCE RETAINS
TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY.
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD HAVE
THE FREEDOM TO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT THE PROPER USE OF THEIR
RESOURCES AND THIS BILL GIVES
THEM THAT FREEDOM.
I ASK COLLEAGUES WHERE YOU'RE
AYE VOTE.
THANK MISS ROMMEL'S.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE ITEM.
CAR CLUB IN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
RESERVE OUT ALL OVER SWEATERS
OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE.
SIXTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEMS FORTY FIVE FORTY SIX
AND FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN PASS
RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM.
FOR EIGHTY EIGHT AJ ARE.
NINE GREGORY.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
IMMIGRATION.
GARCIA.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS I SAYS ENGAGE IN
PREDATORY PRACTICES AND RECESS
IN CALIFORNIA FOR MANY YEARS THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER ON ENHANCING
PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE INTERIOR
OF THE UNITED STATES.
SIGN ON JANUARY TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN ALLOWS ICE TEAS ALL
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS AND EIGHTEEN AND
ASSISTING WITH ARREST.
BRENT IS A THE EXPECT IT IS SUCH
AS OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH ADMINISTRATION OR OSHA.
HAVE IN THE PAST BEEN USED BY AS
TO MAKE ARRESTS AND THIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER WE OPERATE THIS
LIFE USE THIS AND OTHER AGENCIES
IN MAKING IMMIGRATION RELATED
ARREST.
I SAYS ALL SOMEPLACE TACTICS
SUCH AS MAKING A RESIDENTS THEY
SPACES LIKE COURTHOUSES.
AND THEY SHAMEFUL ROUTE USED BY
ICE IS ANNOUNCING THEMSELVES AS
POLICE AND TAKING FULL ADVANTAGE
OF LANGUAGE VERY IS TO TRICK
THOSE TARGET IT.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
TAKEN STEPS TO ENSURE THE SAFETY
OF OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
THROUGH LEGISLATION.
ICE CONTINUES TO THE PLOIDY
THESE PEOPLE TACTICS AND RUTH AS
IN CALIFORNIA.
I JUST EFFECTIVELY UNDERMINE IN
A ROW TO THE TRUST OF CAL
CALIFORNIANS AND IT'S IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY.
AND HAS PLACE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS IN
DANGER.
BY READING THIS TRUST BECAUSE OF
THE FEAR OF NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES AND ARE BEING
APPREHENDED BY ICE WORKPLACE
HAZARDS.
HEALTH VIOLATIONS FEARS AND MINE
IS INJURIES ARE GOING I REPORTED
TO OSHA.
CRIMES ARE NOT REPORTED TO OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES DUE TO
THEIR OCEAN I TRUST WHICH I SAYS
CREATED.
BILLS ARE REPORTED CRIMES MAKE
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND SAFE NOT
JUST OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR CANNOT
INVESTIGATE ILLEGAL WORK PLEASE
PRACTICE THIS UP THERE BECAUSE
THOSE WHO ARE EXPLOITED ARE
MEMBERS OF OUR MOST NOTABLE
COMMUNITIES.
AND WILL NOT FILE REPORTS THE TO
THE PIER AND THE LOSS OF TRUST
AND AGENCIES ASSIGNED TO PROTECT
THEM.
THIS RESOLUTION WILL ARTS A
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO INSTRUCT
AYE FOR STOP USING THE SEQUEL
AND DANGEROUS RECESS AGAINST
IMMIGRANTS AND TO REVISE THESE
TACTICS EMPLOYED BY ICE.
IN ORDER TO THE RICH RESTORE OUR
RIGHTS AND KEEP US SAFE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AJ ARE NINE
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT TACTICS.
FILIPINO CAUCUS POLICY
PRIORITIES INCLUDE DEFENDING
CALIFORNIA VALUES BY PROTECTING
DUE PROCESS AND RIGHTS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
IRRESPECTIVE OF STATUS.
RECENT TACTICS USED BY AYE AYES
ARE CONCERNING.
I'M JUST THE TENSION AND BLANKET
RATES OF UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
GO AGAINST CALIFORNIA'S VALUES.
ARE COMMUNITIES LIVING IN FEAR
AND IS UNCERTAIN OF THE IF OF
THEIR FUTURE.
THESE TACTICS MY STOP AND WE
URGE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
STOP THESE PREDATORY POLICIES.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON AJ ARE.
NINE THANK YOU IS RUBIO SEEING
NO ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION.
MS GARCIA YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH AND WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE FIRST ROLE.
YES PLEASE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE FIRST ROW CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON AG ARE
NINE THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
KIRK WELL CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE
FORTY THREE CO AUTHORS ADDED
THIS IS AN AJ ARE.
THEREFORE WE WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE.
CORPORAL.
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE [inaudible]
DESIRABLE [inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSER ALL THE TIME ABOUT.
ICE FORTY SIX KNOWS.
NINE AT IS ADOPTED [inaudible]
FILE ITEM. FOUR EIGHTY NINE AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO AND
ACTUALLY TO BUSINESS.
MR CHOW EMAIL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT OR CCPA
PROHIBITS ANY BUSINESS FROM
SELLING THE PERSONAL INFORMATION
OF MINORS SIXTEEN YEARS OF AGE
AND UNDER WITHOUT THE PRIOR.
OFTEN CONSENT.
THIS BILL AB SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE
WILL REQUIRE SOCIAL MEDIA
INTERNET WEBSITES OR
APPLICATIONS TO OBTAIN PARENTAL
CONSENT.
WHICH IS SEPARATE FROM THE
GENERAL TERMS AND CONDITIONS
PRIOR TO SELLING AND MINERS
PERSONAL INFORMATION SUCH AS FOR
THIRD PARTY ADVERTISING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THE THANK YOU MICHELLE ST NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM GLOBAL ROLE.
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE [inaudible]
DESIRABLE [inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CULTURAL AND TELL YOU ABOUT AYE
SIXTY KNOWS.
TO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FOR NINETY IS A BEFORE
OF SEVEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR OH SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
MR SANTIAGO YOU MAY OPEN.
I THANK YOU MISTER MEMBER AB
FOROS SEVEN WE'RE PROVIDING
EASIER AT PROCESS TO THE STATE'S
CURRENT LOSS COULD BE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO.
SEEINGNO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS FOLKS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE
FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WE WANT
TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM.
FOR NINET ONE PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM.
FOR NINETY TWO BY A LOT OF FOUR
NINETY THREE CB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS COURT AGREED WITH
AMENDMENTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO WITH THE MEMONS BY SOMETHING
MEMBER DAVID CHIU.
MR CHU THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WOULD
PROVIDE RENT GOUGING PROTECTIONS
FOR TENANTS AGAINST THE MOST
EGREGIOUS RENT INCREASES WHILE
ALLOWING LANDLORDS TO MAKE A
FAIR RATE OF RETURN ON THEIR
INVESTMENT.
BY ESTABLISHING A CAP ON THE
ANNUAL RENT INCREASE OF THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX PLUS 5% AN
AVERAGE OF SEVEN AND A HALF TO A
PERCENT A YEAR. TO ADDRESS RENT
GOUGING.
TODAY MAKING AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION AND MEMBERS WERE NOW
INCLUDING A TEN YEAR SUNSET DATE
TO PROVIDE LANDLORDS AND THOSE
IN THE RENTAL HOUSING INDUSTRY
WITH STABILITY AS THIS BILL
PROVIDE SOME STABILITY TO
RENTERS. TO ENSURE THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT DETER HOUSING
PRODUCTION OR NEW CONSTRUCTION
WE WILL BE EXEMPTING NEW
CONSTRUCTION NEW HOUSING UNITS
UP TO TEN YEARS OLD.
AND ARMAMENTS ALSO CLARIFY THE
DEED RESTRICTED PROPERTIES IN
SOME INSTANCES CAN GO TO MARKET
RATE BEFORE BEING SUBJECT TO
THIS BILL.
THE CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE
BUT I APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL SO FAR
AND WITH THAT AS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN THESE MOMENTS.
THEY MISSED YOU.
THE SCENE NO DISCUSSION.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY YES HAVE AT
THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED.
BILLS OUT TO PRINTER BACK ON
FILE.
FILE ITEMS.
FOR NINETY FOUR AND FOR NINETY
FIVE PASS RETAIN WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM
FOR NINETY SIX
WE ARE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN.
ON FILE ITEM.
FOR NINETY SIX AS WELL AS FILE
ITEM.
FOR NINETY SEVEN THAT BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM FOR NINETY EIGHT A.
B. SIX NINETY SEVEN BY MISTER
TANG CORRECT.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY SEVEN
BY SELLING MEMBER TING AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID.
MR TAKE EMAIL BUT YOU AB.
SIX NINETY SEVEN IS AN A BILL IN
REACTION TO THE COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS CRISIS THAT REALLY
GRIPPED.
THE COUNTRY.
WELL WHAT WE ARE ASKING IS FOR
THOSE INSTITUTIONS IN OUR STATE.
WHO TAKE CAL GRANT FUNDS IN
OFFER PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT TO
ALUMNI AS WELL AS TO DONORS?
THAT THEY MERELY REPORT THE DATA
ON HOW MANY ALUMNI AND DAUGHTERS
THEY ADMIT.
IN HOW MANY OF THOSE WHO THEY
ADMITTED WELL ACTUALLY DID NOT
MEET THE USUAL ADMISSIONS.
CRITERIA SO WE HAVE CHANGED OUR
BUILDING TO MERELY JUST ASKING
THESE INSTITUTIONS TO REPORT
SOME OF THE MACRO DATA.
THAT THEY CURRENTLY DON'T OPPOSE
REPORT BUT ACTUALLY WE GIVE US A
SENSE OF HOW WIDESPREAD -- THIS
ISSUE IS WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE ON A. B..
SIX NINE SEVEN A RESTING.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CAR CLUB IN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS.
THESE ARE VOTE ON MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
AYES.
FORTY THREE KNOWS ONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
FOR NINETY NINE IS H. A R.
ELEVEN CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION ELEVEN
BY SOME REMEMBER CARILLO AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO IMMIGRATION.
MISS KOREA ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I AM
PROUD 2%.
ASSEMBLY DON'T RESOLUTION ELEVEN
WHICH STRONGLY URGES THE
PRESIDENT THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS TO PASS THE DEVELOPMENT
RELIEF EDUCATION FOR ALIEN
MINERS ALSO KNOWN AS THE DREAM
ACT. TO PROVIDE A PERMANENT
SOLUTION FOR IMMIGRANT YOUTH AND
THOSE PROTECTED UNDER TEMPORARY
PROTECTED STATUS OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS TPS AND DEFERRED ENFORCEMENT
DEPARTURE KNOWN AS DVD.
AJ ARE ELEVEN ALSO SUPPORTS
HOUSE RESOLUTION SIX WHICH
REINTRODUCES THE DREAM ACT WHICH
WITH PROTECTIONS FOR T. P. S.
AND DEFERRED ENFORCEMENT
DEPARTURE RECIPIENTS.
AJ ARE ELEVEN EXEMPLIFIES THE
POLICY PRIORITIES OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS TO PROMOTE FEDERAL
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION REFORM.
TO PROVIDE A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP.
AS AN IMMIGRANT FROM MORE
INTERNAL THOUGHT I UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE NECESSITY
OF TPS FROM FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE.
SINCE ITS ORIGINAL INTRODUCTION
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE THE DREAM
ACT AIMS TO PROVIDE A MULTI
PHASE PROCESS FOR QUALIFYING.
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT YOU TO
SEEK RESIDENCY AND A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP.
BEEN CONTINUOUSLY DEBATED
HOWEVER CONGRESS HAS BEEN
UNWILLING. TO TAKE ACTION SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND ONE FOR THAT REASON
I AM HONORED TO JOIN THE EFFORTS
OF CONGRESSWOMAN LUCILLE ROYBAL
ALLARD IN SUPPORTING THE
REINTRODUCTION OF THE DREAM ACT
IN ENSURING A TRUE PATHWAY FOR
CITIZENSHIP FOR OUR YOUTH.
A STATE COURTS CONTINUE TO RULE
IN BOTH DHAKA TPS AND DD
PROGRAMS IT IS CRUCIAL THAT
CONGRESS GREAT THE PERMANENT
SOLUTION. FOR OUR NEIGHBORS
TOUCH BY BOTH PROGRAMS THIS
RESOLUTION ENJOYS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION ON THIS H.
A R. -- MISS CREEL YOU WOULD
LIKE THE FIRST ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON AJ ARE
ELEVEN THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ADDING ON
TO THE RESOLUTION [inaudible]
CLARK WELL. ZERO THERE ARE FORTY
SIX CO AUTHORS ADDED.
THIS IS AN AJ ARE WE WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE CARPOOL OF THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
NO.
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM FIVE HUNDRED IS AB.
ELEVEN THIRTY TWO CLICK READ.
ASSEMBLY ELEVEN THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS [inaudible]
MR GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB
ELEVEN THIRTY TWO WHICH WILL
HELP CRACKDOWN ON CALLER ID
FRAUD AND SPAM CALLS.
AS FAR TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS
KNOW THESE ABUSIVE PRACTICES
HAVE BECOME INCREASINGLY COMMON
IN POST SERIOUS REST TO
CONSUMERS.
MORE RECENTLY FRAUDSTERS HAVE
BEGUN TO SPOOF THE NUMBERS OF
LEGITIMATE GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY TWO WILL
ADDRESS A LOOPHOLE IN THE LAW TO
HELP INCREASE PENALTIES AND AND
THESE ABUSIVE PRACTICES.
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
CORPORAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
LOS THE ROLE TELL ABOUT ICE.
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
FIVE A ONE THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM. FIVE OH TWO AB FIFTY
NINE BY MISTER KALRA COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY NINE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER KALRA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS.
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ON A BILL FIFTY NINE BILLS UPON
OUR STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
INCREASE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND
VOTER TURNOUT AMONG YOUNG VOTERS.
THE BILL WOULD PRIORITIZE A
PLACE ONE OF THE VOTE CENTER OR
SATELLITE OFFICE ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES ACROSS THE STATE.
HAVING ACCESS TO A BOTH CENTER
CAN EASILY RESOLVED EVERY REASON
A PERSON MAY.
HAVE THE PREVENTION CASTING
ABOUT.
WHETHER THEY MOVE FORGOT TO
REGISTER LOS ABOUT HAVE WORK ON
TUESDAYS ON OF STAMPS WHATEVER
MIGHT BE.
I CAN ALL BE SOLVED BY VISITING
ABOUT CENTER.
COLLEGE CAMPUSES ARE UNIQUELY
SUITED TO HOST VOTE CENTERS AND
SATELLITE OFFICES BECAUSE THEIR
HOME. 218-224-18220 FOUR YEAR
OLD AGE GROUP THAT HISTORICALLY
TURNS OUT TO VOTE AT VERY LOW
RATES AND OFTEN.
SPACES -- BASES THESE BARRIERS
TO CUT CASTING ABOUT.
I BRING A VOTE SENATOR THEM IN
MAKING THESE SERVICES READILY
AVAILABLE WE CAN MAKE PROGRESS
ON THE PERPLEXING CHALLENGER
INCREASING TURNOUT.
AMONG THIS VOTING DEMOGRAPHIC AB
FIFTY NINE EMPOWERS ENGAGES
YOUNG PEOPLE WHICH WILL IN TURN
DECREASED THE DISPROPORTIONATE
PRESENTATION VOTER TURN OUT.
AND MOVE US TOWARD A MORE ACTIVE
DEMOCRACY BUT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
[inaudible]
AMOS KALRA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OUR CLUB THE ROLE [inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSER ALL THE TIME ABOUT.
AS FIFTY FOUR NO STATE.
DAD MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
FIVE OH THREE AB FOR THIRTY
CALGARY.
A SOME PEOPLE FOR THIRTY BY
SELLING MEMBER GALLAGHER AND
ACTUALLY TO HOUSING MR GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB FOR THIRTY THE CAMPFIRE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN CREATES AN
EARLY APPLIED STREAMLINED.
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
REBUILDING HOMES.
IN THE AREAS AFFECTED BY THE
CAMPFIRE.
THE CAMPFIRE AS YOU KNOW IS THE
MOST DESTRUCTIVE AND DEADLY IS
FIRING CALIFORNIA STATE HISTORY.
DISPLACING FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
AND DESTROYING ALMOST TWENTY
THOUSAND STRUCTURES.
THE FIRE DESTROYED 14% OF BUTTE
COUNTY IS HOUSING STOCK AND THE
RENTAL VACANCY RATE FELL TO
NEARLY 0%.
AFTER THE FIRE.
THEY'RE ALSO FELL SEVENTEEN
PLACES ON THE AFFORDABILITY
INDEX MORE THAN ANY OTHER AREAS.
OF THE STATE.
THE CITIES OF CHICO IN ORVILLE.
IT WAS RECENT OUTS BY DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE INCREASE THEIR
POPULATION BY 20%.
THAT'S FROM FIRE VICTIMS COMING
INTO THESE JURISDICTIONS NOT
BECAUSE HOMES HAVE BEEN BUILT.
IT IS ESSENTIAL TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING AND IMPACTED
JURISDICTIONS TO MAKE UP FOR THE
MASSIVE HOUSING LAWS FROM THE
CAMPFIRE AND TO ALLOW EVACUEES
THE ABILITY TO STAY IN THE
REGION.
WHERE THEY HAVE JOBS FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY TIES?
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
MEMBER FROM GLENDALE IN THE
CHAIR OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE. FOR HER WORK IN
HELPING ME ON THIS BILL.
I BELIEVE THIS IS A GOOD PIECE
OF LEGISLATION WE'VE COME UP AND
COME UP WITH.
I LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS ON ON THIS
BILL AS IT MOVES ON TO THE
SENATE AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS GALLAGHER DOCTOR
QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
ODDS THIS IS JUST A REALLY
IMPORTANT BILL FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN HURT SO MUCH BY THE
FIRE.
IT'S SOMETHING WE ALL NEED TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
FOR LOOKING AT THE BILL IT DOES
PROTECT ENVIRONMENTALLY
SENSITIVE AREAS IT MAKE SURE
THAT.
PEOPLE ARE NOT PUT IN HIGH FIRE
RISKS JONES UNDER THESE
REGULATIONS IT HAS APPROPRIATE
PROTECTIONS.
AND I THINK IT'S JUST REALLY
GOING TO HELP THE PEOPLE OF THIS
AREA THANK YOU.
A DECK DOCTOR QUIRK MISTER DALLI
YOUR RESIDENTS DAVIS IS BIGGER
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS.
UP GREAT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
MANY OF OUR LOCAL AREA I LOST A
ELEVEN THOUSAND MY CONSTITUENTS --
IN YEAH JUST ABOUT PARADISE WAS
ALSO IMPACTED BY THE CAMPFIRE
AND SO I GLAD TO BE A CO AUTHOR%
ON THIS BILL AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
TO HELP THE IMPACTED FOLKS THAT
TO HAVE BEEN DISPLACED OUT OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU MISTER DALLI SAY NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OF THE
ITEM.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CULTURALTELL ABOUT AYE SIXTY
FOUR KNOWS.
ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FIVE OH FOUR PASS
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM FIVE OH FIVE EIGHTY
SIX FORTY SEVEN COOPERATE.
AS ONLY WILL SIX FORTY SEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER KALRA AND
ACTUALLY TO HAZARDOUS MATERIALS.
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB SIX FORTY SEVEN REQUIRE
COSMETIC IN DISINFECTING
MANUFACTURES WHO ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED UNDER CURRENT LAW. TO
DEVELOP SAFETY DATA SHEETS TO
POST THEM ONLINE AND TRANSLATE
INTO PROMINENT LANGUAGES SPOKEN
BY SALON PROFESSIONALS SALON
PROFESSIONALS MANY WHOM EVER
GRANTS WOMEN OF COLOR AND HAVE
LIMITED ENGLISH SKILLS.
ARE EXPOSED TO BEAUTY CARE
PRODUCTS CONTAINING A MULTITUDE
OF CHEMICALS KNOWN OR SUSPECTED
TO CAUSE HARM TO THEIR HEALTH.
SPECIFICALLY AB SIX FORTY SEVEN
TAKES A SIMPLE AND MODEST STEP
TO INCREASING TRANSPARENCY AND
WORKER SAFETY AWARENESS BY
REQUIRING STUPIDITY SHE'S BE
POSTED ONLINE.
AND AVAILABLE IN COMMON
LANGUAGES SPOKEN BY SALON
PROFESSIONALS.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN
SIMILAR STEPS IN THE PAST
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
OUR SALON PROFESSIONALS THIS
BILL WILL CONTINUE THIS GOOD
WORK BUT THAT ARE STRICTLY ASPEN
AYE VOTE.
THERE WAS KALRA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COUPLE OF THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE FIFTY
THREE KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM FIVE OR SIX A.
B. SEVEN TWENTY NINE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL SEVEN TWENTY NINE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER KANSEN CHU
AND ACTUALLY TO RECYCLING.
MR KANSEN CHU YOU MAIL BUT I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I RISE 2% A. B. SOMEONE
TWENTY NIGHT.
OF FOLLOW UP BILL TO MY BILL
LAST YEAR TO IMPROVE CARPET
RECYCLING IN CALIFORNIA.
AB SEVEN TWENTY NINE WOULD
REQUIRE A BRIDGE OR OF THE
CONTINGENCY PLAN. TO AVOID
DISRUPTING CALIFORNIA'S CARPET
RECYCLING EFFORT AND PROTECT
FEES PAID BY THE CONSUMERS
CUSTOMERS -- IN INDICATES THAT
THE MANUFACTURER RUN STAY CARPET
STORE SHOULD PROGRAM IS
DISAPPROVED OR REVOKED. TO
CONTINUE THE PROGRAM AB SEVEN
TWENTY NINE REQUIRED TO CARVE
HIS TOUR SHOULD ORGANIZATION TO
DEPOSIT FUNDS INTO A TRUST OR
ESCROW ACCOUNT. TO RETAIN
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM IN THE
CASE THE PROPOSED PLAN IS JUST
APPROVED IN ADDITION THIS BILL
RE INCREASE THE MAXIMUM PENALTY
FOR VIOLATORS. TO A TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A DAY.
IN ORDER TO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
TO DO FOR DETERRED FUTURE
VIOLATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR EYE
BELOW [inaudible]
DAME ISSUE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLARK LOVE THE ROLE.
THERE IS HAVE A ISSUE WITH THE
VOTING MECHANISM
.
ISRAEL WAS RESTRICT THE WRONG.
ONE AND THE MINOR GLITCH WITH
THE VOTING MECHANISM. FOR A
STRIKE THE ROLE
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
CLICK OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
JUST ABOUT A FIVE MINUTE PAUSE
WE'VE GOT TO REBOOT THE VOTING
MECHANISM
[inaudible]
RIGHT
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING.
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A SLIGHT
DELAY.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
AND GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES WE
WILL RETURN TO REGULAR BUSINESS.
ONCE WE HAVE COMPLETED THE
ADJOURNMENTS IS GOING TO TAKE A
FEW MINUTES. FOR THE SYSTEM TO
COME BACK ONLINE.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THE QUORUM
CALL IN PLACE WE'RE GONNA KEEP A
QUORUM CALL IN PLACE.
AND WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED THE GERMANS
IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR [inaudible]
MR.
GALLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMAN IN MEMORY MEMBERS MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION
MISTER DALLI WILL BE INTERNING
IN THE MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I IT WENT TO A GERMAN MEMORY OF
A MAJOR JOHN II KLOECKNER SENIOR
JOHN LIVED A LIFE LONG TO FIND
BY SERVICE.
HE COMPLETED A DISTINGUISHED
TWENTY TWO YEAR MILITARY CAREER
SERVING IN BOTH THE INFANTRY AND
SPECIAL FORCES.
WHERE HE WAS A DECORATED WITH
HONORS INCLUDING PURPLE HEART?
BRONZE STAR.
SOLDIER MEDAL FOR HEROISM.
AND THE COMBAT INFANTRY BADGE.
HE WAS INDUCTED INTO THE
INFANTRY HALL OF FAME AT FORT
BENNING IN APRIL OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN AFTER RECEIVING A
MEDICAL RETIREMENT.
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE JOHN
[inaudible]
CONTINUOUS USUALLY.
JOHN CONTINUE TO SERVICE FOR HIS
COMMUNITY.
HE IS A FOUNDER IN THE FIRST
CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA VA HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM ADVISORY COUNCIL.
AND WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN GETTING
THE VA OUTPATIENT CLINIC IN
REDDING.
HS NEARLY TWO DECADES OF AGASSI
WORK HELPED ESTABLISH THE STATE
VETERAN CEMETERY AND VETERANS
HOME AND SHASTA COUNTY.
JOHN WAS TRULY EXCEPTIONAL
CHARACTER AND AT THE WORK ETHIC
WHEN HE FELT HE COULDN'T DO
ENOUGH TO ASSIST VETERANS.
WITH LEGAL MATTERS E WENT BACK
TO COLLEGE AT AGE.
SIXTY TWO AND GOT A DEGREE SO HE
COULD HELP THEM.
HELP THEMSELVES COMPLETING A
TOTAL OF FIVE COLLEGE DEGREES
AND HIS LIFE.
THAT IS THE TYPE OF GUY JOHN WAS
HE WAS ALWAYS THE FIRST TO STEP
UP AND TAKE THE LEAD SHOWING
OTHERS THROUGH HIS ACTIONS THAT.
THEY COULD DO BETTER MEMBERS.
MISTER SPEAKER I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF JOHN II
COLLECTOR [inaudible]
JUST SENIOR.
THANK YOU MISTER DALLI.
MR MCCARTY.
PARDON ME MR MCCARTY OR
RECOGNIZE FOR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I I
RISE WITH THE SADNESS TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF OUR BISHOP FRANCIS
ANTHONY QUINN.
HIS FAMILY IS ALSO HERE WITH US
TODAY A BISHOP QUINN PASSED AWAY
RECENTLY -- IN MY DISTRICT --
WHICH OF COURSE -- BRINGS US A
STATUS IN THE COMMUNITY WHO KNEW
HIM WELL BUT I AM PLEASED TO
SHARE HIS -- HIS MEMORY HIS LIFE
OF SERVICE AND DEVOTION.
HE DISCOVERED HIS CALLING TO
PRIEST IT AS A YOUNG AGE WHILE
SERVING AS AN ALTAR BOY LIKE SO
MANY OTHERS HE GRADUATED FROM
SAINT JOSEPH'S COLLEGE.
ST PATRICK'S SEMINARY IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND THEN EARNED A
MASTER'S FROM CATHOLIC
UNIVERSITY IN WASHINGTON DC AND
A DOCTORATE.
AT UC BERKELEY IN EDUCATION.
HE LETTER LOCAL DICES HERE. FOR
DECADES AND IS MOST REMEMBERED
FOR HIS HUMBLE CHARACTER.
HIS COMPASSION EXTENDED TO THOSE
LIVING ON THE MARGINS IN OUR
SOCIETY -- TO MINISTERING THOSE
ON DEATH ROW TO GOING TO OUR
LOCAL COUNTY JAIL TALKING TO
INMATES THE WORKING WITH THOSE
WHO WERE DYING OF AIDS.
HE FREQUENTLY CONTRIBUTED
GROCERIES TO OUR FOOD CLASS FOOD
CLOSETS AND ALSO ROAN CASE
STREET MALL RIGHT OVER HERE.
SLIPPING TWENTY DOLLAR BILLS TO
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
I THINK HIS GREATEST LEGACY IS
LEFT ABOUT TWO MILES FROM HERE.
THERE IS A HOMELESS -- FACILITY
THERE QUINN COTTAGES IN HIS NAME
WHICH SERVES INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
GETTING OFF OF THE STREETS AND
TRANSITIONING TO A BETTER LIFE.
AND HIS LEGACY LIVES ON WITH HIS
WORK HERE IN OUR COMMUNITY HE IS
SURVIVED BY SISTER BEATRICE HIS
NIECES.
DONNA BRADSHAW AND JOANNE HANSEN
AGAIN I ASKED WE DURING HIS
MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
MCCARTY.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I RISE TODAY TO TURN IN THE
MEMORY OF PRETE THING OF SERVE
YOU DOES WHO IS FATALLY SHOT ON
MAY FOURTEENTH AT HIS PLACE OF
BUSINESS.
MR THING WAS FORTY FOUR YEARS
OLD HE WAS BORN IN INDIA BUT
MOVED TO THE UNITED STATES AND
HOPE FOR A BETTER LIFE.
HE DECIDED TO MOVE HIS FAMILY
SPECIFICALLY TO SERVE YOU DOES
BECAUSE OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
HE WAS ONE OF TWO CORNERS OF ASL
LIQUOR AND MARKETING DOWNEY.
MR THING LIKE THE VETERAN WHERE
YOU WHERE YOU SIR THAT SERVICE
SERVE HOSPITAL COURSE MAN
THINKING CLASS IN THE US NAVY AT
CAMP PENDLETON.
FELLOW NAVY OFFICERS DESCRIBE
THEM OFF THE WALL RESPECT AND
FAMILY MAN WITH A GOOD SENSE OF
HUMOR.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS CALL HIM G. P.
I REFER TO HIM AS A BEAUTIFUL
SOUL. ONE OF HIS SONS TO
HOSPITAL THING HAS SAID AS
FATHER WAS LIKE HIS BEST FRIEND.
HE LEAVES BEHIND HIS WIFE AND
TWO SONS AGES TEN AND SIXTEEN
YEARS OLD.
HE WAS THE HUSBAND FATHER AND
MILITARY VETERAN.
THESE GIVE HIS FAMILY AND THE
COMMUNITY IN YOUR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS GARCIA.
MISTER GIBSON YOUR RECORD ASH
FEAR GERMAN A MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO A
JOURNEY IN MEMORY OF BETHANY
HOKEY.
BORDER REYES IN COMPTON WAS THE
MOTHER OF A BEAUTIFUL SIX YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER.
THAT THE NAME WAS TWENTY THREE
YEARS OLD WHEN SHE WAS KILLED
THE DAY BEFORE MOTHER'S DAY.
I WANT TO ALSO ADD THAT SHE WAS
SHE WORK WITH MY YOUNGEST SON.
AND ALSO THEY BECAME VERYVERY
CLOSE AND VERY SPECIAL FRIENDS.
SHE WAS ON A WAY TO PICK UP
[inaudible]
HER DAUGHTER.
WHEN SHE WAS BLIND SIDED BY GRAY
INFINITY?
THAT WAS DRAG RACING WITH
ANOTHER CAR.
IN WILLOWBROOK.
AFTER THE CRASH THE DRIVER OF
THE INFINITY AND THE PASSENGER
JUMPED OUT INTO A SECOND VEHICLE
A RED SEDAN AND THEY BOTH TOOK
OFF.
AND THEY'RE STILL AT LARGE
BETHANY WAS PRONOUNCED DEAD.
AT THE SCENE THE SUSPECTS ARE
STILL AT LARGE AND I URGE --
INDIVIDUALS TO KNOW ANY
INFORMATION PLEASE SHARE THAT
WITH AUTHORITIES BETHANY WAS A
MOTHER A SISTER A DAUGHTER AND A
FRIEND.
WITH SUCH A BEAUTIFUL.
UNIQUE PERSONALITY SHE DIDN'T
DESERVE THIS.
WE WILL MISS HER.
MEMBERS ARE ASKED THIS BODY
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
BETHANY -- GAME.
THANK YOU MISS GIPSON.
MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK MISS BIGGER MEMBERS SO I'M
ASKING THAT WE ADJOURNED.
IN MEMORY OF THAT MARY ALICE
COLUSA DIAN.
MARY ALICE PASSED AWAY ON MAY
NINTH SHE WAS SURROUNDED BY
LOVING FAMILY AND DEAR FRIENDS.
SHE HAD A FOR FULFILLING CAREER
IN RETAIL AND MANAGEMENT AT GOT
SHOCKS IN FRESNO.
AND THEN MERRY ALICE BEGAN HER
TWO DECADE LONG CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE WHERE SHE WOULD.
BE THE DISTRICT DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLYMAN AND
THREE STATE SENATORS IN A TWENTY
FOUR YEAR CAREER.
SHE BECAME A UP WELCOME
EFFECTIVE -- AND VERY LOVABLE
FIXTURE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
HER FIRST JOB IN THE LEGISLATURE
WAS FOR ASSEMBLYMAN CHUCK BUT
SHE CAN.
I HOLD THE LEGACY SEAT THAT
CHUCK PERCY BUT SHE AGAIN.
HELD IN FRESNO.
AND THAT KNEW HER WELL WHILE I
WAS MAYOR AND WHILE CHECK WHICH
AGAIN SERVED.
UP HERE SHE CONTINUED AS THE
DISTRICT DIRECTOR WHEN CHUCK WAS
ELEVATED TO THE SENATE AND
FOLLOWING US SENATOR PER CHEEK
IN MERRY ALICE SERVED AS
DISTRICT DIRECTOR FOR SENATOR
DAVE COBB DON'T.
AND THEN FOR SENATOR TOM
BERRYHILL SHE RETIRED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AFTER A DISTINGUISHED
CAREER.
MARY ALICE WAS A VERY PROUD OF
HER ARMENIAN HERITAGE SHE WAS A
DEVOUT MEMBER OF HOLY TRINITY
OUR MEANING ARMENIAN APOSTOLIC
CHURCH.
I SHE WAS KNOWN FOR HER.
LIVING LIFE LARGE FOR A
PERSONALITY THAT WAS.
NOT JUST EFFECTIVE IN WHAT SHE
DID BUT JOYOUS ARE AND SHARING
WITH ALL -- SHE WAS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY -- THE ASSEMBLY
OFFICES OF MR PER CHICKEN AND
THE SENATORS THAT I MESSED IT
MENTIONED WERE SO WELL REGARDED
FOR CONSTITUENTS SERVICES.
AND FOR THE GOOD WORK THAT SHE
DID SHE WAS PRECEDED IN PASSING
BY HER PARENTS.
GRANDPARENTS IS SURVIVED BY HER
SISTER BROTHER IN MANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF HER EXTENDED FAMILY.
WE WILL ALL MISS HER VERY MUCH
HER WARMTH HER LOVE AND HER VERY
BIG PERSONALITY THANK YOU FOR IT
ADJOURNING IN MEMORY -- IN IT IN
MEMORY OF THIS VERY WONDERFUL
SERMON.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON.
AND MR BIGELOW YOU ARE ALSO
RECOGNIZE ON THIS A GERMAN IN
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE -- SIMPLY JUST TO ECHO
WHAT OUR COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO
HAS JUST SAID.
MARY ALICE WAS A CLOSE AND DEAR
FRIEND OF MINE AND I I TRULY
ENJOYED THE TIMES THAT WE HAD
TOGETHER.
BUT MORE THAN THAT SHE WAS A
TRUE SERVANT TO THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHEN SHE SPOKE SHE COMMANDED A
PRESENCE IN THE AUDIENCE THAT
WAS LIKE NO OTHER SHE WAS THAT
KIND OF PERSON SHE WAS A
SWEETHEART?
AND SHE KNEW WHAT THE ISSUES.
ON TOP OF THAT SHE ALSO KNEW OUR
BOSSES WERE AND SHE UNDERSTOOD
THE CLARITY OF HER POSITION.
AND SHE MADE SURE HER BOSSES
WERE ALWAYS TAKING CARE OF AND
OUR BOSSES WERE NOT JUST THE MEN
THAT WERE OUTLINED IN.
OUR GOOD SPEAKER AND
REPRESENTATIVE FROM FRESNO SHE
WOULD SPEAK FOR ANY OF US ON
THIS FLOOR WHEN CALLED. TO THAT
THAT REPRESENTS A TRUE GOOD
PUBLIC SERVANT WITH THIS I ASKED
THAT WE ALL ADJOURN IN HER
MEMORY MISS MERRY ALICE
COLLEGIAN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW MEMBERS
PLEASE READ THE NAMES OF THE
DEATHS. TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
ALL REQUESTS TO JOURNAL MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MEMBERS WE ARE AWAITING AN
UPDATE ON THE VOTING SYSTEM IN
THE MEAN TIME WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF SECOND READING ITEMS.
BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE IN THE
SIXTY NINE TO ALLOW MEMBERS TO
TAKE UP LATE AMENDMENTS TO THE
FOLLOWING BILLS.
ITEM FIFTY EIGHT AB THREE THIRTY
TWO LACKEY ITEM SEVENTY SIX A.
B. FOR TWENTY FIVE COOLEY.
AN ITEM FOR NINETY SIX A. B.
THIRTEEN NINETY SIX OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THAT REQUEST IS GRANTED
.
MEMBERS THE WILLIE BROWN ROOM.
EVENT IS STILL OCCURRING RIGHT
OFF OF THE FLOOR RELATED TO THE
STATE FAIRS.
ACKNOWLEDGMENT AND RECOGNITION
OFF OF THE FLOOR.
AND NOW WE WILL MOVE
[inaudible]
TO SECOND READING.
CLERK WILL READ.
IT'S ONLY WILL 569-101-62320
835-373-9401 444-055-05160
869-123-1261 313-513-6130
916-163-1661 751-761-81190
519-620-9213 221-228-23230
523-624-03240 725-225-8260.
327-127-8280 528-929-6302
303-304-3083 1-331-432-9330
1-332-339-3402 340-435-4360.
FIVE THREE SIXTY EIGHT THE
693-723-78380 639-340-2406.
409-411-4154 1-942-542-8420
943-744-09450 246-346-6470
647-748-4894 975-005-08520
1-529-539-5405. 555-255-5550
655-756-7570 ONE FIVE EIGHTY ONE
SIX SO 761-262-5620 963-563-9640
261-676-58660 1-662-668-6716
776-786-8680 FOUR SIX EIGHTY
FIVE SEVEN A 1-708-713-7157
272-275-1760. 977-678-3780
478-779-8800 803-826-8298
398-401-8402 840-885-2870
585-894-8989.
007-917-9199 269-279-4049
629-679-7970 SIX TEN OO TO TEN
OO 410-191-02210 251-027-2020
810-402-1040 610-511-05210.
581-061-1060 610-801-08510
861-088-1090 210-981-10411.
SIXTEEN ELEVEN SEVENTEEN ELEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN ELEVEN FIFTY THREE
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO ELEVEN
EIGHTY ELEVEN NINETY ONE ELEVEN
NINETY SIX TWELVE SEVENTEEN
TWELVE NINETEEN TWELVE TWENTY
SEVEN TWELVE THIRTY TO TWELVE
FORTY NINE TWELVE FIFTY THREE
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE TWELVE SIXTY TWELVE SEVE
1-150-515-0915. ELEVEN FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN FIFTEEN NINETEEN FIFTEEN
TWENTY AND
FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE
FIFTEEN TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN
TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN FORTY EIGHT
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT FIFTEEN NINETY FIFTEEN
NINETY THREE FIFTEEN NINETY
SEVEN SIX SIXTEEN OH THREE
SIXTEEN OH SIX SIXTEEN THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN FOURTEEN SIXTEEN FORTY
FIVE SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN SIXTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
EIGHT SIXTEEN SE.
CAN CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT.
ONE ASSEMBLY BILLS WITH
AMENDMENTS. 248-153-03230
840-340-7671 331-402-1641
651-711-73170 419-720-3204
211-232-2405 275-300-3073
1-031-731-8320 324-333-3373
383-403-57370 638-839-7403
417-423-4264. 544-794-93512 FIVE
FIFTEEN FIVE EIGHTEEN BY TWENTY
SIX FIVE THIRTY ONE FIVE CINDY
259-459-8614 627-638-6386
566-636-73680 1-694-718-7197.
317-337-34740 474-087-52750
576-376-4760 777-380-7820
483-184-03840 985-785-9860
587-990-1914 939-339-36940
295-496-9639 659-719-0879.
NINETY FIVE ONE THOUSAND AND ONE
ONE THOUSAND AND SEVEN ONE
THOUSAND AND TEN ONE THOUSAND
AND 311-033-1060 810-251-07610
971-122-1120. 811-301-13111
331-175-1180 FOUR TWELVE OO TO
TWELVE TWELVE TWELVE FOURTEEN
TOLD 291-233-1240 612-751-32113
311-340-1340 313-561-36214
003-141-01430 514-361-48640.
871-494-1540 415-505-07816
1-116-231-6426 277-168-11680
717-051-72517 291-759-1770
917-831-80840 812-586-1930 ONE
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN OH SIX
TWO NINETY FOUR FOURTEEN EIGHT
NINETY ONE THIRTEEN TWELVE ONE
SIXTY ONE FIVE TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY FIFTY EIGHT SEVEN TWO NINE
ELEVEN AND ONE THOUSAND AND
NINETY THREE ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED.
ADOPTED THANK YOU KATIE
AS WE
CAN ENTERTAIN VOTE CHANGES AT
THIS TIME.
SERVO CHANGES FROM YOUR DESK.
FOR ME DESK.
MR CHIU YOUR RECOMMENDS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER FOR FILE ITEM
FORTY NINE CHAO AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
FIVE MODE CHANGE NO TWO I VOTE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU.
AS LABEL SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE NOTE
I DOCTOR QUIRK THOUGH CHANGE
SEEMS TO BE AN EPIDEMIC ON THIS
BILL.
OUR FILE FOR EIGHTY NINE A. B. --
SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE CHIU -- NO TO
I'D.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE
NO TO AYE
.
DOCTOR QUIRK HERE MICROPHONE
WE
HAVE ANY OTHER VOTE CHANGES ANY
OTHER VOTE CHANGES
.
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN OF THE
FLOOR THERE'S ONE ITEM WE HAVE
ON CALL.
IN THAT WILL BE I BELIEVE THE
EXTENT OF THE BUSINESS WE ARE
ABLE TO TAKE UP TODAY WE HAVE
ONE ITEM THAT IS ON CALL.
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR.
SO WE MAY LIFT THE CALL WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A VOICE VOTE.
ON MEMBERS WHO HAVE NOT VOTED ON
THAT ITEM
.
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR SO WE MAY DISPENSED WITH
THE ONE ITEM THAT'S ON CALL.
IS MR MERCY CHEESE ITEM
MEMBERS.
IF I COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION
RATHER UNORTHODOX SITUATION.
BUT WE HAVE A BILL THAT IS ON
CALL.
WE ARE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL.
A NUMBER OF MEMBERS.
HAVE CHOSEN TO THIS POINT TO NOT
VOTE ON THE ITEM WE ARE GOING TO
THE SIMILAR DO WE DO IT A
SIMILAR -- TO A COMMITTEE VOTE.
WE ARE GOING.
TO CALL THE MEMBERS WHO HAVE NOT
SIGNIFY TO VOTE AT THIS TIME.
PLEASE SIGNIFY YOUR VOTE ON THE
RECORD THEM. FOR THE JOURNAL.
MEMBERS I'M PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM FOR SEVENTY
ONE THIS IS AB. TWELVE EIGHTY
SIX AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
CERVANTES I COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM I DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER -- WHEN [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LACKEY I LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
SALAS AYE STONE.
STONE I WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I BEFORE WE CLOSE RIDE
LIKE A RECOGNIZED HIS POWER QUE
HAND FROM YOUR DESK ON THE VOTE
CHANGE.
BAUER-KAHAN IS NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
THOUGH CHANGE.
OUR CANNOT VOTING.
ICE FORTY SEVEN KNOWS TWELVE
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS YOUR CALL VERY BRIEFLY
THAT WE MADE A PROCEDURAL MOTION
ON TAKING UP THREE ITEMS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS LATE
AMENDMENTS.
ITEM FIFTY EIGHT AB THREE THIRTY
TWO BY MR LACKEY.
THIS IS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS.
SOME PEOPLE THREE THIRTY TWO
WITH A MOMENT BY FAMILY MEMBER
LACKEY.
MISTER LACKEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THESE
ARE TECHNICAL MEMBERS RE PHRASE
TRAINING REMEDIATION AS REMEDIAL
TRAINING AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE FELL.
ON THE TO MANAGE ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED THAT BILL IS OUT TO
PRINTED BACK ON FILE.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX AB FOR
TWENTY FIVE COOLEY BUT MS IRWIN
WILL BE PRESENTING.
THE AMENDMENTS CLERK READ WITH
AMENDMENTS.
AS I'M ABLE FOR TWENTY FIVE WITH
THE MEMONS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY.
MS OR ONE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
AB FOUR TO FIVE NARROWLY EXAMS
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR SECURITY
COMPANIES WHICH ARE READY
LICENSE TO CARRY FIREARMS FROM
FACE TO FACE TRANSACTION
REQUIREMENT FOR AMMUNITION
PURCHASES.
THESE CHANGES HELP STREAMLINING
CLARIFY PAPERWORK PROCESS TO
HELP LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THOSE SECURITY COMPANIES
COMPLY WITH THESE NEW LAWS
AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK CLARIFY
THAT PAPER WORK NEEDS TO BE
FILED FIRST LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
SO THAT THEY CAN PROPERLY
RECEIVE.
AMMUNITION FROM VENDORS OUT OF
STATES.
THERE DRAFTING A LOT TO BE IN
LINE WITH PROP SIXTY THREE AND
OTHER STATUTES REQUIRE --
REGULATING AMMUNITION
[inaudible]
PURPOSES.
I THANK MY ANSWER WOULD BE
ADOPTED BUT I PRINT.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE HEARD ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES
HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR
BILLS OUT TO PRINT TO BACK ON
FILE.
AND FINALLY ITEM FOR NINETY SIX
A. B. THIRTEEN NINETY SIX FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CLERK
WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS.
AS LEGAL THIRTEEN NINETY SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE MR
OBERNOLTE ANY MINUTES THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB THIRTEEN
NINETY SIX EMPOWERS A JUDGE WHEN
ISSUING.
AN ELDER ABUSE RESTRAINING ORDER
TO ORDER AN OFFENDER TO CLINICAL
COUNSELING OR ANCHOR MANAGEMENT
THESE AMENDMENTS IMPLEMENTED
SUGGESTIONS MADE BY THE GENERAL
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THEY APPROVE
THE BILL.
REQUEST DRIVE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL WILL BE
SENT OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON
THE FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER OF AN AUNTIE.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAME THE EYES
HAVE IT.
MM SIR ADOPTED THE BILLS OUT TO
PRINT.
AND BACK ON FILE
.
THE ONLY ONE WE PASSED SEVERAL.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK
TO FILE ITEM.
FOR NINETY ONE AB EIGHT FORTY
SIX MS BURKE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS.
CLERK WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
AS LEGAL EIGHT FORTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS BY FAMILY MEMBER
BURKE.
MS BURKE ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AMENDMENTS TO
IT -- AB FORTY SIX REMOVE ANY
CHANGES TO THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACTS OF
NONDISCRIMINATION SECTION AND
INSTEAD SEPARATELY ADDS EXPRESS
RECOGNITION IN THE C. C. P. A.
FOR LOYALTY REWARD PROGRAMS.
AND IT ADDS CO AUTHORS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN I. BUT
THANK YOU IS.
FOR WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
DOCTOR THAT BILLS OUT TO PRINT
IN BACK ON FILE.
ANNOUNCED RECESSION SCHEDULE IS
AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY MAY TWENTY
FIRST CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY
MAY TWENTY SECOND FLOOR SESSION
AT TEN AM.
THURSDAY MAY TWENTY THIRD FLOOR
SESSION AT TEN AM THURSDAY MAY
TWENTY FOURTH FLOOR SESSION IS
AT NINE AM ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN.
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING AND HEARING A FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MR
FLORA SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL WEDNESDAY
MAY TWENTY SECOND.
AT TEN AM OF THE QUORUM CALLS
LIFTED